welcome to the simply learns YouTube
channel we've been following the trend
of taking up a challenge to learn the
fundamentals and brush off the skills of
a trending technology within a week data
science week software development week
by simply learn are brilliant examples
to name a few now this week is dedicated
to learning devops this interesting week
will help you learn all the fundamentals
and improve your devops skill set but
before we begin let me tell you guys
that we have daily updates on multiple
Technologies if you are a tech geek in a
continuous hunt for latest technological
Trends then consider getting subscribed
to our YouTube channel and don't forget
to hit that Bell icon to never miss an
update from Simply gone devops is a
software development and operations
approach that enables faster development
and deployment of software products and
easier maintenance of existing
deployments by eliminating the
compatibility barriers separating the
developers and operations teams should
you ask how well that's exactly our
first session in devops week without
further Ado let's get started we shall
begin with having a basic understanding
of devops with a short animated video
after that we shall dive deeper and
understand what devops is all about we
shall see what is its relevance in the
present scenario
we shall learn different Tools in a
Learning Journey the tools that we shall
see are get Gradle Maven selenium Docker
Chef ansible puppet negios and Jenkins
after we have a fair amount of knowledge
regarding devops and devops tools we
will look at the interview questions
that will increase our chances to crack
any devops interview now without any
further Ado let's begin with our
animated introduction
controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner Mia's house Mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction Mia is now really
annoyed and she has a lot to correct and
it seems to her as though Tim didn't
really do much this wall between them
leaves a poor robot to bite the dust
well what if he broke this wall Tim and
Miana work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as in when a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the module fuels and
the algorithms to use once he has the
plan he now codes the plan with tools
such as git Tim has a repository for
storing all the codes and their
different versions this is call Version
Control next this code is fetched and
made executable this is the build stage
tools such as Gradle and Maven will sort
this out now before deployment the
product is tested to catch any bugs the
most popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
Mia must deploy it the deploy product is
then continuously configured to the
desired State ansible puppet and Docker
are some of the most common tools used
that automate these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this phase and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration let's now have a look at an
organization that has adopted the devops
approach which of the below sequence of
steps would they follow to develop a
software linear answers in the comment
section keep an eye out for the right
answer on the comment section or our
YouTube Community
Giants such as Amazon Netflix Target
Etsy and Walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality T in 2014 an hour
of downtime for Netflix would cost it
two hundred thousand dollars it became
absolutely crucial that Netflix prepared
themselves for any sort of failure and
so they took to the devops approach and
implemented it in the most unique way
they developed a tool called the Simeon
Army this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its Divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future we're going to go through what we
need to be able to do to go to devops
what the arguments are and why you need
to do devops and they're all actually go
through all the individual tools you
need to be able to successfully
Implement devops within your
organization in addition to that we're
also going to take time and go through
each of those tools so you get a good
understanding of a step-by-step
instructions on how to do basic setup of
each of those tools so let's get started
so what was devops before so what was
the process that we took for doing
delivery before devops well it was a
model called waterfall and waterfall was
a very traditional approach to actually
building out Solutions and the reason
why it's called waterfall is that you
bring out all the individual
requirements and individual sections of
a project and they Cascade off each
other so if we look at the breakdown we
have requirements design and we have
implementation we have verification we
have maintenance you'll have user
acceptance testing now this is all based
on the software development lifecycle
model or sdlc and it's been around for
quite some time and it's still used by a
lot of companies today okay the
challenge you've had with the waterfall
model is that it really is a very long
drawn out model for actually building
and delivering Solutions so it took a
very long time to actually write code
and then deploy the code and it was very
difficult to actually identify problems
within the code and provide feedback to
the development team on what to fix and
this really was a very time consuming
we're talking about months sometimes
years for projects to be actually go
through a war film model process so
Along came a new method of being able to
do delivery and it's called agile and
the agile approach is a way of being
able to take the actual work that's done
in a waterfall model and compress it
down into small iterations and what we
would do is a fundamental changes that
you would actually take teams that were
disparate and as part of the individual
Cascades within a waterfall project and
you actually bring them together so you
have your requirements team in person
design developer and release management
team all together in one group working
on an iteration the great thing about
agile is that you took a process that
was weeks or months or even years in
length as it was with waterfall and you
reduce it down to two or four week
Sprint depending on the Cadence for your
team typically you have a two-week
spring and then the goal is is that at
the end of each Sprint or sometimes
every other Sprint you would do a
software release and so that customers
were getting the software much faster
the problem that we still ran into
though with um agile is fundamentally
similar to what we were having with
waterfall you have your devops person
working on code on their system and
you'd be working great on their computer
and then you have the operations person
who's migrating the code from the
developers environment the test
environment to for the production
environment and you run into issues
where the code simply wasn't working
there's a lot of reasons why that would
happen the actual developer environment
would often be very different or would
have different dependencies in it so the
the hardware the the software there may
be additional uh applications that were
installed on the operating system that
simply hadn't been transferred over to
the operations environment and so what
you would have is a disconnect between
the developer environment and the
operations environment making it
difficult
um to actually roll out code so you'd
run into a program where when you rolled
out code you'd have to have a rollback
plan in case the code wouldn't work in
production and so each release became an
event where everybody got very stressed
about the actual event of releasing code
because you didn't know whether it was
going to work so Dev Ops really looks to
address and solve a lot of these
problems so the key word that you'll
often hear with devops is continuous
integration and what that means is
essentially that as a developer is
working on their code the code is
constantly being tested against not just
the actual code itself with unit testing
but the environment with which it's
going to be released in and the goal
from a devops model is that the
breakdown of communication that happens
with waterfall and agile where Dev
developers and operations teams aren't
working in the same environment is being
removed and you're able to provide a
continuous and contiguous environment
between the developer and the actual
operating model so the reality is when
the developer is working on their code
they're actually working in an
environment that is identical to the
production environment and so when the
actual operations person comes to
actually do releases for the code and
you can see some teams are doing as many
as 20 to even up to 50 releases to
production environments every single day
you're able to guarantee that the actual
code itself will work and releases go
from being a stressful event to a
byproduct of good testing and good setup
and structure for how you actually build
out your Solutions so what we're seeing
here so the goal is that as a developer
and as an operations person that the
code is working continuously in both
environments you have continuous
integration and continuous delivery so
simply put what we're able to do is
we're able to eliminate the problem of
the operation environment not being in
sync with the development environment
and this is a Improvement on agile this
is not to say that waterfall or agile
are wrong as delivery models what it is
is just a maturity of the ability to
deliver Solutions and devops is just
another rung in that maturity curve
using tools that are available to us now
that five ten years ago simply weren't
available so the goal is for you as a
team to move to a devops model where you
can Implement continuous releases on
your software as long as you're using
the tools that are available and the
good news is those tools are open source
tools so let's go through some of the
benefits of why you'd want to go and use
devops so you know essentially what's in
it for you so that's over the next few
sides we're going to go through what is
devops we're going to go through the
benefits of devops so in the last few
slides you've actually seen you know
what is devops and the benefits of
devops along with the life cycle but
we're also going to start digging into
the tools that you have that are useful
for devops and we're going to focus in
on seven tools that can provide an
end-to-end infrastructure for delivering
devops Solutions with there are
significantly more tools available on
the market but these are seven of the
most popular for each of their
categories so demo helps really is an
essential collaboration between the
development team and the operations team
these are teams that have in past been
somewhat at conflict with each other and
what you have now is an opportunity
where those teams can now work
continuously with each other the
expectation with devops is that it will
continue to mature indeed you're
actually even seeing some groups which
are now called devsecops where they're
integrating security as part of the
delivery between the development team
and the operations team the bottom line
is a devops engineer is highly in demand
the demand for devops engineer is
literally going through the roof with
salaries going up exponentially around
that so let's dig into some of the
benefits of devops it's not just a new
catchphrase it's actually got
significant value and how you can speed
up delivery of your software so the
benefits of devops can really broken up
into a number of key areas first of all
we have continues to delivery of
software which allows you to
continuously release new features with
the security and understanding that the
software going out is of high quality it
allows the teams that are working on the
software delivery within your
organization to more effectively
collaborate with each other so that
you're all talking from the same page
and understanding of what needs to be
delivered the deployment process itself
moves from being an event where there's
a lot of stress and there's a lot of
contingency plans to being a much easier
deployment the efficiency within the
actual code that you're writing and the
ability to scale up using the different
tools are available it allows you to be
able to bring in and scale up and reduce
the teams you have running the software
as needed errors can be fixed much
earlier and more quickly and can be
caught before anything gets pushed out
to the production environment and
fundamentally what we're looking for is
improving the security of the actual
releases so the actual concept of
security is Center to all the work
you're doing and then finally what
really allows you to reduce the number
of Errors is that there is much less
manual intervention there is a greater
Reliance on scripted environments that
you can actually test and validate for
their security reliability and uptime
efficiency so let's talk a little bit
about the life cycle of a devops so the
very first step that you'll take is to
actually build out a build and test
environment and this is a continuous
building test environment and this is
managed probably the first step of your
source code once you move through that
and you're looking at continuous
integration which means that every time
somebody checks in their code they're
validating that the code actually can
run in the production environment once
you've actually then passed the end
continuous integration and the testing
that you have with your code you're
looking at continuous deploy employment
if the code works and is available to be
released into the production environment
let's go ahead and release it and once
you actually have release code then you
want to be able to validate that your
environment is working efficiently you
may release code that is a new feature
within your application and customers
May then gravitate immediately to that
new feature if they do you want to be
able to ensure that the code is working
and more importantly but the
infrastructure is there to support and
then finally you're looking at software
released as a continuous event and then
you go back to the beginning you start
working on more code you run it through
your build environments and continuous
integration deployment continuous
monitoring and keep that cycle moving so
let's dig into the tools that you as a
devops engineer would need to learn if
we break down the environment that we
have all the way from source code
management to software release and there
are a number of key tools that you want
to be able to use so for instance source
code management and get is an open
source tool that you would want to use
for managing your code The Continuous
build and test environment will be
managed with Maven and selenium
integration with the environments that
you're working on is managed through
Jenkins the actual deployment to your
production environments will be managed
with products such as ansible and Docker
and then the monitoring of your network
would be used with tools like nelios the
thing that you have to remember with all
these tools is that they're open source
tools there is no licensing that you
have to purchase some of the tools will
have our Pro level licensing that you
can choose to select but to get started
all of these are open source tools you
can actually start using for free right
now we are going to dive deep and
understand the top 10 reasons why you
should learn devops so what is devops
devops is a collaboration between the
development and operation teams which
enables continuous delivery of
applications and services to our end
users before devops there was a lot of
communication gap between the
development and operation teams the code
that used to work fine on the
development side would create a lot of
errors on the operation side this in
fact led to a lot of issues the biggest
issue was the delay in Project delivery
the solution to this was devops in
devops the operation and development
Engineers participate together in the
entire life cycle from the design
through the development process to the
delivery of the software to the end
users it enhances the process to deliver
the software faster and a software of
high quality if there is any bug or
error it is fixed at the right time
rather than dragging it to the last
phase let's now look into the 10 reasons
why you should learn devops
so at number 10 we have technical
cultural and business benefits of devops
let me explain each benefit one by one
so first we have the technical benefits
continuous software delivery is the most
important process of delivering the
software in smaller increments to ensure
that the software can be released at any
time with this approach of devops the
team will always be ready on delivering
anytime it has the benefit of having
less complex problems to fix the code is
tested at every stage and both the
development and operation teams make
sure that the complexity is reduced to a
great extent devops also has the benefit
of faster and easier resolution to every
problem if any bug or error is founded
in earlier stage it is fixed and then
moved on to the next stage hence this
way at the final stage there will be
zero or minimum number of bugs moving
forward let's look into the cultural
benefits of devops the workload is
divided equally between all the
employees so no individual is under the
pressure to code test debug an entire
software this results in a team that is
happy and more productive since devops
is a collaboration between the
development and operation teams if any
issue arises on one side the team is
always ready to help and the employees
are engaged to make sure that the
software is as the end user requires and
hence is delivered at the set date
devops helps in increasing the
professional development opportunities
finally let's look into the business
benefits of devops the basic principles
of devops that is automation continuous
delivery and quick feedback cycle aim to
make the software development process
faster and more efficient being an
extended version of agile methodology
devops ensures that the complete
software development lifecycle goes
smoothly by promoting collaboration
between the teams devops offers
continuous feedback so that the errors
are fixed in time and the releases are
done faster these days the development
teams need to break down the
interdepartmental constraints planes and
collapsed it as well as communicate in a
dynamic round-the-clock environment
devops gives a way to improve the
business agility by providing an
environment of mutual collaboration
communication and integration across the
various teams in an IT organization all
the team members are responsible for
meeting the quality and timeline of the
software deliverables with devops
organizations can improve the deployment
frequency recovery rates and hence
result in a lower failure rate with
every new release it is possible to
ensure the reliability and stability of
an application when applications perform
flawlessly in the market organizations
reap the benefits of Greater customer
satisfaction at the ninth position we
have work with good developers per code
is all too common sadly users arrive at
the realization when it's too late the
fact is some developers are good at what
they do While others have poor coding
skills a team of software developers
consists of excellent good average and
poor developers it is important that the
bad course generated by many developers
need to be stopped as it may increase
the production time devops helps in
reducing the bad code limits as the bad
code cannot go to the next phase until
it is fixed also a team member who is
terrible at coding could be good at any
other different roles and vice versa
re-tasking team members earlier in the
process prevent wastage of time and
resources so in this way devops
eliminates bad developers and ensures
that the team comprises of good
developers next at eighth position we
have increased efficiency due to
increment in efficiency level it results
in speeding up the process of
development and also makes it error free
devops can also increase efficiency
through automation there are many ways
to automate tasks in devops devops
allows Engineers to focus on those tasks
which are not automated there are
certain tools of acceleration that
increase the efficiency they are the
cloud-based platforms or other scalable
infrastructure which help in increasing
the access of the team to the hardware
resources and hence speeds up the
process of testing and deployment
operations with the use of built
acceleration tools the code compiles
faster there may be a process that helps
in embedding parallel workflows into the
continuous delivery chain so that the
delays are avoided moving on at 7th
position we have a better organizational
culture with the help of devops there
has been an improvement in software
development the development and
operation teams are more focused on
performing together rather than having
separate goals the team is more focused
on production if both the teams are
combined it will result in innovative
ideas in a very efficient and effective
manner there is improved collaboration
and communication between the team
members devops facilitates better
understanding among the team members and
this understanding increases worker
morale next at the sixth position there
is faster release of software it is true
that devops makes the processes of
software development agile hence it
leads to the timely release of the
software companies can quickly study the
behavior of users and incorporate the
changes to come up with a better product
this in turn helps the organization to
stay competitive there is a reduction in
rollbacks and failure rates regarding
deployment and the time that is taken to
recover with better products devops
reduces the time for cycles of
development and also ensures a faster
rate of innovation at position 5 we have
better knowledge of software delivery
life cycle once you get to know about
devops you will get a lot of information
about the software delivery life cycle
it is divided into main phases like
planning analysis design implementation
testing and integration and maintenance
in the plan phase initially there should
be a plan for the type of application
that needs to be developed getting a
rough picture of a development process
is always a good idea in analysis a
detailed study of requirements is done
to check whether all the requirements
are available or not the list of all the
requirements like human resources
Hardware software required to accomplish
this project successfully will be
clearly analyzed and listed out here in
the design phase the whole project is
divided into modules each module into
sub modules by drawing some diagrams
using unified modeling language a pseudo
code will be prepared at this phase in
the implementation phase the application
is coded as per the end user
requirements coder now has the task to
do the coding developers will develop
the actual Source Code by using the
pseudo code and following the coding
standards the testing and integration
phase is the most important step of the
application development here the
application is tested and rebuilt if
necessary the multiple modules of codes
from different programmers are finally
integrated into one then finally the
application is developed and delivered
to the end users the Final Phase is
maintenance once the client starts using
the develop software then the real
issues start coming up in this stage the
team is required to fix the issues roll
out new features and refine the
functionalities as required at the
fourth position we have Boost product
quality the concept of devops does not
allow mistakes in the stage of
methodology when both the operation and
development stages are done correctly
with no errors then it will result in a
release of better and improved product
qualities this leads to a cleaner more
efficient code and hence increases the
software quality with each release the
DeVos process brings better quality to
the development process and reduces the
chances of unplanned work at the third
position we have exposure to trending
Technologies and advanced tools the
Wolves works with a variety of tools few
of them are nagios Chef Docker git
selenium puppet kubernetes ansible and
many more you will get a chance to
understand and use all these tools and
learn how to design develop deploy and
maintain an app or software with the
help of these tools apart from that by
knowing all things about such software
and tools you can increase your chances
of getting hired by the best companies
at the second position we have increase
your professional credibility by
obtaining a devops certification you can
increase your professional credibility
this certification will help you to let
the others know that you have sufficient
skills in monitoring a software's
performance easily write and code with
scripts enhancing the software's
security to a greater extent providing
the best it Hardware you will be able to
troubleshoot various issues in the
software and finally you will be able to
connect softwares databases and much
more to ensure if effective
functionality 42 percent of companies
are now preferring open source jobs and
want candidates with devops skills so if
you want to become a part of developing
the devops your market then this is the
perfect time to start getting devops
training and finally the top reason to
learn devops is to get a perfect job and
increase your salary divorce is a very
popular career choice now researchers
have also shown that in the coming years
devops will be the main hiring criteria
for 46 percent of the it companies
however they are not sufficient experts
who can match the requirements that's
why they are massive opportunities for
candidates seeking devops jobs besides
when it comes to salary you can earn a
lot of money on an average a divorce
professional gets a pay of 99
604 dollars per annum in the United
States and a divorce professional in
India gets an average salary of 6 lakhs
2000 rupees per annum now let me recap
and call out all the 10 reasons for
learning devops once again at number 10
we had the technical cultural and
business benefits of devops at number
nine we had work with good developers at
number eight we had increased efficiency
at number seven we had a better
organizational culture at number six we
had faster release of software then at
fifth position we had better knowledge
of the software delivery life cycle at
the fourth position we had boost product
quality and at third position we had
exposure to trending Technologies and
advanced tools at the second position we
had increasing professional credibility
and finally at the top position we had
get a perfect job and increase your
salary now let me tell you how simply
learn can help you learn devops so that
you can start your career in it so guys
this is the official simply learn
website and I'm gonna show you the
different types of devops courses simply
learn offers so first is devops engineer
let's go ahead and look into that this
is a Masters program and it has seven
plus real life projects
you can see the course curriculum here
that is git and GitHub training devops
certification training devops and AWS
and more
you can see the learning objectives
the tools covered here are maven ansible
shift puppet salt stack Apache Jenkins
team City and many more you can see the
course curriculum
and you can see the electives that you
can choose
okay let's go back and look at another
certification
we had the devops certification training
so here you have 56 hours of Blended
learning over 10 industry projects with
integrated Labs 24 hours of live demos
and you have flexibility to choose the
classes the skills covered are divorce
methodology Version Control Systems
continuous integration and deployment
tools and Jenkins team City Maven and
many more
so you can see the benefits here the
annual salary of a devops professional
the companies that are hiring devops
professional
then we can see the course curriculum we
have introduction to devops Version
Control Systems continuous integration
continuous deployment then we have
software and automation testing
Frameworks we have containerization with
Docker and much more
and you can see the various tools that
are involved in this then we have our
industry projects
so guys in this way simply learn can
help you get a devop certification we'll
start by downloading and installing it
on our system we'll then have a look at
the git bash interface we'll type in
some basic git commands next we'll
create a local repository that is we'll
create a repository on a local machine
we'll then connect to a remote
repository and finally we'll push the
file onto GitHub first things first we
need to download and install git so
download git for Windows and I'll select
the second link
so 2.19.1 which is the most latest
version of git that's the one we want
for Windows system choose your version
so mine is a 64-bit system and it's
downloading so this will take a while so
git is finally downloaded now we need to
install the sonar system
click here run
so go to next we don't have to change
this path uh just so just click on in
quick launch and on desktop next next
again next nothing to change here either
and install
so now git is getting installed on our
system
so we don't need to view the release
notes we just want to launch the git
Bash
so let's just stick that and then click
on finish
and your git bash interface appears here
so we are on the master Branch the first
thing we do is we'll check the version
for our git so the command is git dash
dash version and as you can see version
2.19.1 on our Windows system which is
exactly what we just downloaded we'll
now explore the help command so let's
just type get help config so config is
another command and as I hit enter the
manual page for the second command
opened up which is config so what help
command does is that it provides the
manual or the help page for the command
just following it so in case you have
any doubts regarding how a command is
used what a command is used for all the
various syntax of the command you can
always use the help command now there's
another Syntax for using the help
command itself which is git config dash
dash help enter this does the exact same
thing as you can see
now that we looked at the help command
let's begin by creating a local
directory so mkdir test now test is my
new directory I'll move into this
directory so CD test
great so now that we are inside our test
directory let's initialize this
directory so get init is the command for
initializing the directory and as you
can see as you can see the path here
this is the local path where a directory
is created so I'll just show you the
directory test and it's completely empty
what we do now is we'll create a text
file within this new directory that we
created so new text document and I'll
just name this demo I'll open this and
just put in some dummy content so hello
simply learn
save this file and go back to your bash
interface let's just check the status
now so git status and as you can see our
file has appeared it's visible but
nothing is committed yet so this means
that we have not made any change to a
file through the git tool itself so the
next thing that we are going to do is
we'll be adding demo to our current
directory the next command that we'll be
applying is the commit command and when
you add certain files to the current
directory the comment command is applied
on all the above directories so git
commit minus M and a message that will
appear once the file is committed
so as you can see one file is changed
and one insertion I'll just clear the
screen next thing we need to do is we
need to link our git to our GitHub
account so the command for doing that is
git config Global user dot username
and this will be followed by our
username so let me just show you my
GitHub account
so this is my GitHub profile and my
username is simply learn Dash GitHub so
guys before you begin this procedure
just make a GitHub account type in my
username here simply learn Dash GitHub
and enter and there you go a git is
successfully linked with GitHub next
thing we do is we'll just open our
GitHub and we'll create a new repository
give a repository name so I'll get name
it test underscore demo and create
Repository
great so our repository is created this
is our remote repository what we do next
is just copy the link and then go back
to your bash interface
now we need to link a remote and a local
Repository
so git remote origin and then paste
the HTTP link and now that our local
repository and a remote repository are
linked we can push a local file onto a
remote repository so the command for
doing that is git push origin Master as
we are on the master branch
and that's done so now let's move back
to GitHub I'll just click on test demo
and as you can see here our local file
has been pushed to our remote repository
with that we have successfully completed
our demo all right let's talk a little
bit about Version Control Systems so you
may have already been using a virtual
control system within your environment
today you may have used tools such as
Microsoft's team Foundation services but
essentially the use of a Version Control
System allows people to be able to have
files that are all stored in a single
repository so if you're working on
developing a new program such as a
website or an application you would
store all of your Version Control
software in a single repository now what
happens is that if somebody wants to
make changes to the code they would
check out all of the code in the
repository to make the changes and then
there will be an addendum added to that
so um there will be the version one
change that you had then the person
would then later on check out the code
and then be a version two and added to
that code and so you keep adding on
versions of that code the bottom line is
that eventually you'll have people being
able to use your code and that your code
will be stored in a centralized location
however the charge you're running is
that it's very difficult for large
groups to work simultaneously within a
project the benefits of a VCS system a
Version Control System demonstrates that
you're able to store multiple versions
of a solution in a single repository now
let's take a step at some of the
challenges that you have with
traditional Version Control Systems and
see how they can be addressed with
distributed Version Control so in a
distributed Version Control environment
what we're looking at is being able to
have the code shared across a team of
developers so if there are two or more
people working on a software package
they need to be able to effectively
share that code amongst themselves so
that they constantly are working on the
latest piece of code so a key part of a
distributed Version Control System
that's different to just a traditional
version control system is that all
developers have the entire code on their
local systems and they try and keep it
updated all the time it is the role of
the distributed VCS server to ensure
that each client and we have a developer
here and developer here and developer
here and each of those our clients have
the latest version of the software and
then that each person can then share the
software in a peer-to-peer like approach
so that as changes are being made into
the server of changes to the code then
those changes are then being
redistributed to all of the development
team the tool to be able to do an
effective distributed VCS as
environments is get now you may remember
that we actually covered get in a
previous video and we'll reference that
video for you so we start off with our
remote git repository and people are
making updates to the copy of their code
into a local environment that local
environment can be updated manually and
then periodically pushed out to the get
repository so you're always pushing out
the latest code that you've code changes
you've made into the repository and then
from the repository you're able to pull
back the latest updates and so you'll
get repository becomes the kind of the
center of the universe for you and then
updates are able to be pushed up and
pulled back from there what this allows
you to be able to accomplish is that
each person will always have the latest
version of the code so what is get get
is a distributed Version Control tool
used for source code management so
GitHub is the remote it's a server for
that source code management and your
development team can connect their get
clients to that certain remote Hub
server now git is used to track the
changes of the source code and allows
large teams to work simultaneously with
each other it supports a non-linear
development because of thousands of
parallel branches and has the ability to
handle large projects efficiently so
let's talk a little bit about get versus
GitHub so get is a software tool whereas
GitHub is a service and I'll show you
how those two look in the moment you
install the software tool forget locally
on your system whereas GitHub because it
is a service it's actually hosted on a
website git is actually the software
that used to manage different versions
of source code whereas GitHub is used to
have a copy of the local repository
stored on service on the website itself
git provides command line tools that
allow you to interact with your files
whereas GitHub has a graphical interface
that allows you to check in and check
out files so let me just show you the
two tools here so here I am at the get
website and this is the website you
would go to to download the latest
version of git and again git is a
software package that you install on
your computer that allows you to be able
to do Version Control in a peer-to-peer
environment for that peer-to-peer
environment to be successful however you
need to be able to store your files in a
server somewhere and typically a lot of
companies will use a service such as git
Hub as a way to be able to store your
files so git can communicate effectively
with GitHub there are actually many
different companies that provide similar
service to GitHub gitlab is another
popular service but you also find that
development tools such as Microsoft
Visual Studio are also incorporating git
commands into their tools so the latest
version of Visual Studio team Services
also provides this same ability but
GitHub it has to be remembered is a
place where we actually store our files
and can very easily create public and
shareable is a place where you can store
our files and create public shareable
projects you can come to GitHub and you
can do a search on projects you can see
at the moment I'm doing a lot of work on
blockchain but you can actually search
on the many hundreds of projects here in
fact I think there's something like over
a hundred thousand projects being
managed on GitHub at the moment that
number is probably actually much larger
than that and so if you are working on a
project I would certainly encourage you
to start at GitHub to see if somebody's
already maybe done a prototype that
they're sharing or they have an open and
source project that they want to share
that's already available
um in GitHub certainly if you're doing
anything with them Azure you'll find
that there are thousands 45
000 Azure projects currently being
worked on interestingly enough GitHub
was recently acquired by Microsoft and
Microsoft is fully embracing open source
Technologies so that's essentially the
difference between get and GitHub one is
a piece of software and that's get and
one is a service that supports the
ability of using the software and that's
GitHub so let's dig deeper into the
actual git architecture itself so the
working directory is the folder where
you are currently working on your get
project and we'll do a demo later on
where you can actually see how we can
actually simulate each of these steps so
you start off with your working
directory where you store your files and
then you add your files to a staging
area where you are getting ready to
commit your files back to the main
branch on your git project you want to
push out all your changes to a local
repository after you've made your
changes and these will commit those
files and get them ready for
synchronization with the service and
we'll then push your services out to the
remote repository an example of a remote
repository would be GitHub later when
you want to update your code before you
write any more code you would pull the
latest changes from the remote
repository so that your copy of your
local software is always the latest
version of the software that the rest of
the team is working on one of the things
that you can do is as you're working on
new features within your project you can
create branches you can merge your
branches with the mainline code you can
do lots of really creative things that
ensure the that Aid the code remains at
very high quality and B that you're able
to seamlessly add in new features
without breaking the core code so let's
step through some of the concepts that
we have available and get so let's talk
about forking and cloning in kit so both
of these terms are quite old terms when
it comes to development but forking is
certainly a term that goes way way back
long before we had distributed CVS
systems such as the ones that we're
using with get to Fork a piece of
software is a particularly open source
project you would take the project and
create a copy of that project and but
then you would then associate a new team
and new people around that project so it
becomes a separate project in entirety a
clone and this is important when it
comes to working with get a clone is
identical with the same teams and same
structuring as the main project itself
so when you download the code you're
downloading exact copy of that code with
all the same security and access rights
as the main code and then you can then
check that code back in and potentially
your code because it is identical could
potentially become the mainline code in
the future now that typically doesn't
happen your changes are the ones that
merge into the main branch but also but
you do have that potential where your
code could become the main code with Git
You can also add collaborators that can
work on the project which is essential
for projects where particularly where
you have large teams and this works
really well when you have product teams
where the teams themselves are
self-empowered you can do a concept
what's called branching in git and so
say for instance you are working on a
new feature that new feature and the
main version of the project have to
still work simultaneously so what you
can do is you can create a branch of
your code so you can actually work on
the new feature whereas the rest of the
team continue to work on the main branch
of the the project itself and then later
you can merge the two together pull from
remote is the concept of being able to
pull in Services software the team's
working on from a remote server and git
rebase is the concept of being able to
take a project and re-establish a new
start from the project so you may be
working a project where there have been
many branches and the team has been
working for quite some time on different
areas and maybe you're kind of losing
control of what the true main branch is
you may choose to rebase your project
and what that means though is that
anybody that's working on a separate
Branch will not be able to Branch their
code back into the mainline Branch so
going through the process of a get
rebase essentially allows you to create
a new start for where you're working on
your project so let's go through forks
and clones so you want to go through the
process so you want to go ahead and Fork
the code that you're working on so this
is this scenario that one of your team
wants to go ahead and add a new change
to the project the team member may say
yeah go ahead and you know create a
separate Fork of the actual project so
what does that look like so when you
actually go ahead and create a fork of
the repository you actually go and you
can take the version of the mainline
Branch but then you take it completely
offline into a local repository for you
to be able to work from and you can take
the mainline code and you can then work
on a local version of the code separate
from the mainline Branch it's now a
separate Fork collaborators is the
ability to have team members working on
a project together so if you know if
someone is working on a piece of code
and they see some errors in the code
that you've created none of us are
perfect at writing code I know I've
certainly made errors in my code it's
great to have other team members that
have your bag and can come in and check
and see what they can do to improve the
code so to do that you have to then add
them as a collaborator now you do that
in GitHub you can give them permission
within GitHub itself and it's really
easy to Super visual um interface that
allows you to do the work quickly and
easily and depending on the type of
permissions you want to give them
sometimes it can be very limited
permissions it may be just to be able to
read the files sometimes it's being able
to go in and make all the changes you
can go through all the different
permission settings on GitHub to
actually see what you can do but you'll
be able to make changes so that people
can actually have access to your
repository and then you as a team can
then start working together on the same
code let's step through branching and
get so suppose you're working on an
application but you want to add in a new
feature and this is very typical within
a devops environment so to do that you
can create a new branch and build a new
feature on that Branch so here you have
your main application on what's known as
the master branch and then you can then
create a sub branch that runs in
parallel which has your feature you can
then develop your feature and then merge
it back into the master Branch at a
later point in time now the benefit you
have here is that by default we're all
working on the master Branch so we
always have the latest code the circles
that we have here on the screen showed
various different commits that have been
made so we can keep track of the master
branch and then the branches that have
come off which have the new features and
they can be many branches in git so git
keeps you the new features you're
working on in separate branches until
you're ready to merge them back in with
the main branch so let's talk a little
bit about that merge process so you're
starting with the master branch which is
the blue line here and then here we have
a separate parallel branch which has the
new features so if we're to look at this
process the base commit of feature B is
the branch f is what's going to emerge
back into the master branch and it has
to be said there can be so many
Divergent branches but eventually you
want to have everything merge back into
the master Branch let's step through git
rebase so again we have a similar
situation where we have a branch that's
being worked in parallel to the master
branch and we want to do a get rebase so
we're at stage C and what we've decided
is that we want to reset the project so
that everything from here on out with
along the master branch is the standard
product however this means that any work
that's been done in parallel as a
separate Branch will be adding in new
features along this new rebased
environment now the benefit you have by
going through the rebase process is that
you're reducing the amount of storage
space that's required for when you have
so many branches it's a great way to
just reduce your total footprint for
your entire project so get rebase is the
process of combining a sequence of
commits to form a new base commit and
the prime reason for rebasing is to
maintain a linear project history when
you rebase and you unplug a branch and
re-plug it in on the tip of another
branch and usually you do that on the
master branch and that will then become
the new Master Branch the goal of
rebasing is to take all the commits from
a feature branch and put it together in
a single Master Branch it makes it the
project itself much easier to manage
let's talk a little bit about pull from
remote Suppose there are two developers
working together on application the
concept of having a remote repository
allows the code to the two developers
will be actually then checking in their
code into a remote repository that
becomes a centralized location for them
to be able to store their code it
enables them to stay updated on the
recent changes to the repository because
they'll be able to pull the latest
changes from that remote repository so
that they are ensuring that as
developers are always working on the
latest code so you could pull any
changes that you have made to your
thought remote repository to your local
repository the command to be able to do
that is written here and we'll go
through a demo of how to actually do
that command in a little bit good news
is if there are no changes you'll get a
notification saying that you're already
up to date and if there is a change it
will merge those changes to your local
repository and you get a list of the
changes that have been made remotely so
let's step through some of the commands
that we have in git so get and it
initializes a local git repository on
your hard drive get ads adds one or more
files to your staging area get commit
Dash M commit message is a commit
changes the git command commits changes
to head up to the git command commits
changes to your local staging area get
status checks the status of your account
repository and lists the files you have
changed get lock provides a list of all
the commits made on your current Branch
get diff the user changes that you've
made to the file so you can actually
have files next to each other you can
actually see the differences between the
two files get push origin Branch name so
the name of your branch command will
push the branch to the remote repository
so that others can use it this is what
you do at the end of your project git
config Dash Global username will tell
get Who You Are by configuring the
author name we'll go through that in a
moment git config Global user email will
tell get the author of by the email ID
get clone creates a get repository copy
from a remote source and get remote ad
origin server connects the local
repository to the remote server and adds
the server to be able to push to it git
branch and then the branch name will
create a new Branch for you to to create
a new feature that you may be working on
get checkout and then the branch name
will allow you to switch from one branch
to another Branch git merge Branch name
Will merge a branch into the active
Branch so if you're working on a new
feature you're going to merge that into
the main branch a git rebase will
reapply commits on top of another base
tip and get rebase or reapply commits on
top of another base tip and these are
just some of the popular git commands
there are some more but you can
certainly dig into those as you're
working through using get so let's go
ahead and run a demo using get so now we
are going to do a demo using get on our
local machine and GitHub as the remote
repository for this to work I'm going to
be using a couple of tools first I'll
have the deck open as we've been using
up to this point the second is I'm going
to have my terminal window also
available and let me bring that over so
you can actually see this and the
terminal window is actually running
gitbank measures the software in the
background which you'll need to download
and install you can also run get batch
locally on your Windows computer as well
and in addition I'll also have the
GitHub repository that we're using for
simply learn and already set up and
ready to go all right so let's get
started so the first thing we want to do
is create a local repository so let's go
ahead and do exactly that so the local
repository is going to reside in my
development folder that I have on my
local computer and for me to be able to
do that I need to create a drive in that
folder so I'm going to go ahead and
change the directory so I'm actually
going to be in that folder before I
actually create and make the new folder
so I'm going to go ahead and change
directory
and now I'm in the development directory
I'm going to go ahead and create a new
folder
and let's go ahead and created a new
folder called hello world
I'm going to move my cursor so that I'm
actually in the hello world folder
and now that I'm in the hello world
folder I can now initialize this folder
as a git Repository
so I'm going to use the get command init
to initialize and let's go ahead and
initialize that folder so let's see
what's happened so here I have my Hello
wall folder that I've created and you'll
now see that we have a hidden folder in
there which is called dot gate and we
expand that we can actually see all of
the different subfolders that git
repository will create so let's just
move that over a little bit so we can
see the rest of the work
and now if we check on our folder here
we actually see this is users Matthew
development hello world dot get and that
matches up with hidden folder here
so we're going to go ahead and create a
file called readme.txt in our folder so
here is our hello world folder and I'm
going to go ahead and using my text
editor which happens to be Sublime
I'm going to create a file and it's
going to have in there the text hello
world and I'm going to call this one
readme.txt
if I go to my Hello World folder you'll
see that we have the readme.txt file
actually in the folder what's
interesting is if I select the get
status command what it'll actually show
me is that this file has not yet been
added to the commits yet for this
project so even though the file is
actually in the folder it doesn't mean
that it's actually part of the project
for us to do that we actually have to go
and select
foreign
for us to actually commit the file we
have to go into our terminal window and
we can use the get status to actually
read the files that we have there so
let's go ahead and use the git status
command and it's going to tell us that
this file has not been committed you can
use this with any folder to see which
files and subfolders haven't been
committed and what we can now do is we
can go and actually add file so let's go
ahead I'm just going to select at git
add so the git command is ADD
[Music]
readme.txt so that then adds that file
into our main project and we want to
then commit those files into the main
repositories history and so it's that do
that we'll hit the the get command
commit and we'll do a message in that
commit and this one will be
first commit
and it has committed that project what's
interesting is we can now go back into
readme file and I can change this so we
can go hello get
get is a very popular
Version Control solution
and we'll
we'll save that now what we can do is we
can actually go and see if we have made
differences to the readme text so to do
that we'll use the disk command forget
so we do get
div
and it gives us two releases the first
is what the original text was which is
hello world and then what we have
afterwards is what is now the new text
in green which has replaced the original
text
so what we're going to do now is you
want to go ahead and create an account
on GitHub we already have one so what
we're going to do is we're going to
match the account from GitHub with our
local account so to do that we're going
to go ahead and say get config
and we're going to do Dash and it's
going to be a
globaluser.name and we'll put in our
username that we use for GitHub and this
instance we're using the simply learn
Dash
GitHub account name
and under the GitHub account you can go
ahead and create a new repository name
in this instance we call the repository
hello dash world
and what we want to do is connect the
local GitHub account with the remote
hello world.get account and we do that
by using this command from get which is
our remote connection and so let's go
ahead and type that in open this up so
we can see the whole thing so we're
going to type in git remote add origin
https
GitHub
.com
dash world dot get
that creates the connection to your
hello world account
and now we want to do is we want to push
the files to the remote location using
the get push command commit git push
origin
master
so we're going to go ahead and connect
to our local remote GitHub so I'm just
going to bring up my terminal window
again and so let's select get remote add
origin
and we'll connect to the remote location
github.com slash
simply learn
Dash GitHub slash
hello dash world dot get
oh we actually have already connected so
we're connected to that successfully and
now we're going to push the master Gish
so get
push origin
master
and everything is connected and
successful
and if we go out to GitHub now
we can actually see that our file was
updated just a few minutes ago
so what we can actually do now is we can
go and Fork a project from GitHub and
clone it locally so we're going to use
the fork tool that's actually available
on GitHub let me show you where that is
located and here is our branching tool
it's actually changed more recently with
a new UI interface
and once complete we'll be able to then
pull a copy of that using the forks new
HTTP URL address
so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to go ahead and create a
fork of our project now to do that you
would normally go in when you go into
your project you'll see that there are
Fork options in the top right hand
corner of the screen now right now I'm
actually logged in with the default
primary count for this project so I
can't actually Fork the project because
I'm working on the main branch however
if I come in with a separate ID and here
I am I have a different ID and so I'm
actually pretending I'm somebody else I
can actually come in and select the fork
option and create a fork of this project
and this will take just a few seconds to
actually create the fork
and there we are we have gone ahead and
created the fork
so you want to say clone or download
with this and so this is the I select
it'll actually give me the web address I
can actually show you what that looks
like I'll open up my text editor
oops that's the correct
I guess that is correct
so I'm going to copy that
and
I can Fork the project locally and clone
it locally I can change the directory so
I can create a new directory that I'm
going to put my files in and then post
in that content into that file so I can
now actually have multiple versions of
the same code running on my computer
I can then go into default content and
use the patchwork command
so I can create a copy of that code that
we've just created and we call it that's
a clone and we can create a new folder
that we're actually putting the work in
and we could for whatever reason we
wanted to we could call this where photo
Patchwork and that would be maybe a new
feature and then we can then paste in
the URL of the new directory that has
the forked work in it and now at this
point we've now pulled in and created a
clone of the original content
and so this allows us to go ahead and
Fork out all of the work for our project
onto our computer so we can then develop
our work separately
so now what we can actually do is we can
actually create a branch of the fork
that we've actually pulled in onto our
computer so we can actually then create
our own code that runs in that separate
branch
and so we want to check out um the the
branch and then push the origin Branch
down to our computer
this will give us the opportunity to
then add our collaborators so we can
actually then go over to GitHub and we
can actually come in and add in our
collaborators
and we'll do that under settings and
select collaborators and here we can
actually see we have different
collaborators that have been added into
the project and you can actually then
request people to be added via their
GitHub name or by email address
or by their full name
one of the things that you want to be
able to do is ensure that you're always
keeping the code that you're working on
fully up to date by pulling in all the
changes from your collaborators
you can create a new branch and then
make changes and merge it into the
master Branch now to do that you would
create a folder and then that folder in
this instance would be called test we
would then move our cursor into the
folder called test and then initialize
that folder so let's go ahead and do
that so let's call create a new folder
and we're going to first of all change
our root folder and we're going to go to
development
create a new folder
call it test and we're going to move
into the test folder and we will
initialize
that folder
and we're going to move some files into
that test folder
because one test one
and then when we do file save as and
this one's going to be test
two
and now we're going to commit those
files
and
kit add and then we'll use the
dot to pull in all files
and then git commit
m
files
that's it
make sure I'm in the right folder here I
don't think I was
and now that I'm in the correct folder
let's go ahead and
and get commit
and it's gone ahead and added those
files and so we can see the two files
that were created have been added into
the master
and we can now go ahead and create a new
Branch we call this one get branch
test underscore
branch
and let's go ahead and create a third
file to go into that folder
this is
file three
into file save as we'll call this one
test three dot text
and we'll go ahead and add
that file I need to get add
test three Dot txt
and we're going to move from the master
Branch to the test run branch
kit
check
out test underscore
branch
I switched to the test branch
and we'll be able to list out all of the
files that are in the in that Branch now
and we want to go through and merge the
files into one area so let's go ahead
and we'll do get merge test underscore
branch
as well we've already updated everything
so that's good so otherwise it would
tell us what we would be merging
and now all the files are merged
successfully into the master branch
there we go all my merged together
fantastic
and so what we're going to do now is
move from must to Branch to test branch
so get
check out
test underscore branch
and we can modify the files the test3
file that we took out
and pull that file up
and we can
now modify
and we can then
commit
that file
back
in now we've actually been able to then
commit the file with one changes and now
we've seen as the text free change that
was made
now we can now go through a process of
checking the file back in switching back
to the master branch and ensuring that
everything is in sync correctly
we may at one point want to rebase all
the workers kind of a hard thing you
want to do but it will allow you to
allow for managing for changes in the
future so let's switch to it back to our
test branch which I think we're actually
on we're going to create two more files
let's go to our folder here and let's go
copy those
and that's created
we'll rename those tests
four
and
five
and so we now have additional files
and we're going to add those into our
branch that we're working on so we're
going to go and select get add Dash a
and we're going to commit those files
get
commit Dash a dash m
adding
two new files
and it's added in the two new files
so we have all of our files now we can
actually list them out and we have all
the files that are in the branch
and we'll switch them to our Master
Branch we want to rebase the master
so we do git rebase
master
and that will then give us the command
that everything is now completely up to
date
we can go
get
check out
Master to switch to the master account
this will allow us to then continue
through and rebase the test branch and
then list all the files that are all in
the same area
so let's go get rebase
test underscore
branch
and now we can list and there we have
all of our files listed incorrectly
choose from over 300 in-demand skills
and get access to 1 000 Plus hours of
video content for free visit skillup by
simply learn click on the link in the
description to know more now we will be
talking about it how exactly we can make
use of Maven here in performing various
kind of operations whether it's a burial
compilation with this kind of stuff
there so let's talk about it why exactly
we use Maven here now Maven is something
which is a kind of a build tool which is
there for most of the job-based projects
here so this tool also helps us in
building up the source code by
downloading some couple of dependencies
these dependencies are something which
is being configured by the developers
which a developer feels that uh the
project is dependent on and he requires
those dependencies to be downloaded so
uh this tool is specifically used to
build and manage any kind of a jar based
project whatever the complex city of the
topic or the project is there so this
tool will be able to handle that
particular requirement or that project
so it simplifies the day-to-day work of
a Java developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now Maven also helps us in getting
the uh specific jar files for each and
every project so if you are going you
can pretty much make a jar file bar file
or your file any kind of a package
mechanism you can follow for your Maven
there so to download the dependencies we
don't have to actually go to the
official website of each and every
software you can easily get it uh the
dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh project over here so it
totally depends on how exactly you want
to download and you want to get together
a specific repository over here so mvin
repository.com is the one if you visit
you will be able to download and go
through all the jar files dependent jar
files as independencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is on Maven
all about so let's see on that part so
Maven is a popular open source Bell tool
which is uh developed by the Apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once Maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects written in c-sharp Scala
Ruby Etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a jar
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a Java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build uh perspective
tasks on the projects
right now Maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as in
Project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take care of all the followings here
submitted and standardized here so all
these particular mechanisms is can be
followed as such over here so that we
can have a good standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now in this one we are going to talk
about that how we can work on Maven
installation on Windows and Ubuntu
platform here so first of all we'll do
it on the Windows platform here and
we'll see that how the installation
really works so for this one I will be
doing the installation into my local
system now before even going for me when
Maven is in kind of a build tool which
is available there primary for
performing any kind of build automation
for the Java based projects now since
it's a used for Java we also require the
jdk installation onto our system so for
that both of the installations we will
be covering over here and we'll see that
how the install solution really works as
such over here right so before even
going for Maven we have to install the
jdk onto our Windows machine so that we
can proceed with Maven because Maven
requires the jdk installation should be
there now there are two ways of jdk
installation either you go for the exe
file or you'd extract the binaries of
jdka to a directory and then set up the
Java underscore home path for that but
if you are using the agq table that will
perform the path configurations for you
also so in that case you don't have to
reconfigure it again and again so that's
what we are going to see here so first
of all we will try to do the
installation of jdk so for that we'll go
to the website of jdk and then we have
to click on this one to access the maven
installations part here so that's what
we are going to do so let's proceed and
let's open the Chrome and try to go
through these two URLs so that we can do
the installations one by one
so here I have to just search for jdk8
download so it will show me the URL for
oracle.com so here you will get the jdk
for the different platforms for
different operating systems now here
what you can see here that you have the
configurations in which you have the jdk
installation so we have to so here I'll
go for the windows 64 version because
that is something I will be using to do
the installation so this is the complete
executable link so here you can download
so we are downloading the sdka
u251 so just search for Windows 64 yeah
this is the one so let me click on this
one
let me quickly log into the web page so
once the login is done you will be able
to see that it's trying to download the
exe file so that was for the 3dk for the
Java now for the May one I am going to
go for the maven download over here so
in this one the maven repo link is there
maven.apache dot orj is the link for
this one now here we have the different
options you can see here that the binary
zip archive is there then so save
archive is there so depending on the
installation which you want to perform
you should be able to download that file
and it works there so let's first
install the jdk portion and then we'll
go with this one
so we'll click on this one also anyways
because uh it's something we have to or
anyways do it so we'll click on this so
that uh this Maven is also getting
started install downloading over here so
once both of them are downloaded we will
proceed further with the setup so let's
wait for another one minute to do this
one
so the Apache Maven is kind of uh
downloaded over here so we wait for the
jdk download also over here so next 5-10
seconds only left out
so first jdk will be there and then
Maven installation configurations will
be there so for me when we just have to
extract into a directory and give the MV
in-home paths into the uh properties uh
into the variables so that it can pick
it up over there okay so we have to
extract the zip file for Maven give the
path and then we will treble check with
the maven command whether it's working
fine or not so let's try to install the
executive so we'll open the directory
where the executables are there so first
of all we'll install the jdk so we'll
double click the installer for jdk it's
of around 200 MB so the complete jdk
will be installed so we have to just go
for next now when you go with the
installer so usually the Java home paths
and all that stuff is already configured
so you don't really have to change the
passwords or Java home any kind of
variable you have to put it up all those
things will be automatically cleaned up
so it's running the installation
close so then we have to extract the
maven so we have to extract this
directory because here the maven
complete executables and libraries are
there so we just have to extract it and
place into a directory so that we can
further on use it and access the path so
once the access is done yep so this is
done there so I can rename it to like
miven so I can rename it like to as Mi
one and I can cut it down and put it
into the C drive here now this is the
maven Home Path which is going to be
there right so all I have to do is that
I have to close this one and this one
and this one and this
so what we have to do is that we have to
really go to the system properties so
that we can extract it so I'm going to
open the system properties over here
properties now here the advanced system
settings now in this one we will be
setting up the paths so environment
variable will go now here if you scroll
down you will see all the different
paths which is available there as such
over here now if you want to see that if
the Java is fine or we require for jdk
also so all we have to do is that we
have to open the CMD prompt window R we
are providing so using the window R I'm
opening the Run window where I can say
like CMD now in this CMD I'm going to
say like Java
hyphen version so Java is there so which
means that we don't have any problem as
such now I'll just go here and set up a
new one called mvn underscore home so
here the same path so you can browse for
directory also but I am using the
ambient home over here in this one
now I have just added that and in the
path variable in the last we have to
actually add the bin directory also so
that uh whenever we run the mvn command
so that should also be resolved so mvn
underscore home is not the only variable
which you will be configuring in fact
you will be configuring the path
variable also that you can go ahead and
put up a new directory entry for the CMD
here so CMD tell the CMD directory you
will go there and whatever the
executable is there you should be able
to resolve that so for that again you
have to open the window R CMD prompt
Java hyphen version and then you can run
mvn hyphen version here when you run The
mvn Hyphen version it will let you know
that which particular Java runtime you
are using
1.8.0 underscore 251 that's the same one
which we have configured and it also let
us know that where exactly the
executable is there and we can now
proceed further with the execution of
the maven build so you just have to
check out your source code or go to the
directory where source code is there and
you can run the ambient clean install so
that will ultimately go for the build
process so this is the way that how we
can do the installation of Maven on the
Windows platform now since this is done
now we will go ahead with the second
installation where we are going to do
the installation of Maven and jdk onto
the Ubuntu machine so for that we will
log into the particular Cloud lab of
Simply learn in LMS so let's log into
the LMS here so now we are going to do
the installation of jdk and Maven on the
Ubuntu virtual machine here so for that
we will log into the LMS so let's log
into that so this is the uh elements
over here here I have already started
the lab here so all I have to do is that
I have to just click on this link here
so it will open the lab into a new tab
it's a GUI mode of Ubuntu Server so
which we will be using to configure it
so uh here uh first of all I can open
the Chrome browser also so let me open
the browser here so that I can download
the me1 executables as such over here
so GDK we can do it using the package
installation so using the APT executable
we will be doing the installation so I
have to just open the terminal here so
once the terminal is opened you have to
login through the root ID now why we
require root ID so that we should be
able to do the package installations and
other configurations so that requires
root access
now once that is done you have to run
the particular app update command next
you have to install the installer so the
Oracle installer we have to install now
once the setup is done so let's install
the latest package over here for I call
Oracle hyphen Java 14 hyphen
installation so this will install the
GDK 14 over here so for that
configurations now at the same time
we'll go for Maven download also
so here uh we'll go for download me even
so this is the tar file for executable
so I'm going to copy this URL here
and over here we'll say yes yes
yes
so now uh the Java should be configured
and could should be set up over here in
this one so what we really need to do is
that we need to run the Java command to
see that if the installation is done
properly or not so uh let's open the
terminal again another terminal so that
I can perform these steps related to
maven so I have got the URL so I'm going
to the opt directory which is always an
optional directory where we can do the
setup and all those configurations
so I'm going to run the wget command and
then the URL which I have downloaded so
this should uh download the tar file
over here of Maven now once that is done
so I have to extract it so uh tar hyphen
x v z f and the tar file name this is a
target zip file so I have to use tar
hyphen XP ZF parameter over here to
extract it now what exactly I have got I
have got the Apache Maven directory over
here so I'm going to rename it in order
to rename it what we need to do we need
to actually go for the particular move
command so move whatever the existing
folder you have and then I'm going to
rename it with the maven directory now
once that is done I am going to the
maven directory and this is the path or
Maven underscore Home Path which is
available as such over here in this one
so here all the bin directories
executables all this stuff is there so
now I can use it like mvn underscore
home and the same configuration just
like we did in the window so here also
it the same process we have to follow so
Java hyphen version should be let me
know that which version is deployed so
14.01 version is deployed over here so
for Java I do not don't have to set up
the path again here because I am viewing
for the installer so I don't have to set
up the path
right so for Maven now what exactly I
have to do I have to go to the ETC
profile D now here I am going to put up
a particular file now here you can see
that we have the jdk file here which
means that uh the path variables and
everything is configured as such over
here so you can see that Java underscore
Home Path all these variables are copied
here so I'm going to also create a same
file similar to this one here but in
this case what I'm going to use it that
I'm going to remove some of the values
so I'm going to have some of the
parameters added so in order to do it
effectively I can do the Eco command so
that I can copy the things from here and
I can simply put it up into the file
here so I'm going to have the path
variable added up over here now why I am
putting up the paths because it's the
same configuration which we did over
there also so opt slash May 1. slash pin
so all the bin directory should be added
to the specific path variable so I'm
just trying to create a file called
maven.sh just like a jdk.sh over here
I'm also creating similar kind of file
over here called maven.sh now I'm not
going in the vi mode or other editors
because I just want to make you
understand that how I'm copying it the
content I am taking the jdk.sh as in
reference and putting up the details
over here in this one and then I'm going
to export mvn underscore home over here
which is related to like opt slash
Maven so this is what we are going to
put up over here and then Maven in the
end Maven this is the file which you
should be having now why we are using it
because of the fact that it's being used
or it will be utilized in such a way
that you can perform the changes or
whatever configurations you want to
perform this will help you to set up the
certain parts like a path and ambient
home so that you can run these scripts
as such over here so I'm going to give
the executable permissions to this one
and that's it so now what exactly I have
to do is that I have to do the source
here
profile
dot d maven once that is done I will be
able to run the mvn hyphen version over
here and the jdk part is already open so
it's going to refer to that part so this
is the way that how we configure the Mi
1 and the jdk specifically on the Ubuntu
virtual machine so pretty much that's it
for this demo in this demo we primarily
talked about that how we can do the
installation of Jade again Maven on
Windows and how we can do the similar
task on the maven on the Ubuntu virtual
machine also here hello everyone welcome
to this demo in this demo we are going
to talk about it how exactly we can do
the installation of Maven on the Mac
operating system so here we are going to
talk about it how we can do for a
specific setup where we can do for the
installation of Maven in a Mac operating
system so let's see so there are two
ways of doing the installation here
first is through the view executable on
the Mac now this blue utility on Mac is
just like apt or year utility which is
present in most of the environments or
most of the platforms here but here we
are using this preview to do the
installation of Maven on the Mac
operating system and again this next one
is just in a particular organism where
you should be able to have these setup
like you can download the binders from
the Apache website and then you can
export the M2 underscore home and the
path variable so that you can start
using the maven executable so we'll talk
about these things and we'll see that
how exactly we can go for this setup so
let's login uh to a particular machine
or Mac operating system so where we will
be able to do all this activity
so this is the max system which we have
here now in this one what we are going
to do is that we are going to open the
terminal so we are going to open a
terminal here so this is my terminal so
usually in Mac uh you don't require any
other mechanism so the inbuilt terminal
is more than sufficient for doing the
stuff because it's similar to a Linux
based platform here so I'm going to run
the command here so first of all I'll
just double check that if my Brio
executable is working fine so I'll just
run the Brew help command to see that uh
if my Brew is working fine as such over
here in this one now I have the command
called preview install so that is the
command which we need to use now in this
one we have to actually give the
specific package which we want to
install so we will say like Brew install
maven
so it will download the uh specific
executables on the system
from the website it will download the
maven executables so it will take some
time but ultimately it's trying to
download it under the particular tar
file so you can see here that it's
downloading a 3.6.3 tar file over here
so uh I can see that the installation is
done so the 3.6.3 version should be
installed over here so when I do like
Maven uh mvn under hyphen iPhone version
over here so you can see that the
3.6.3 version is deployed as such over
here now this is something which is done
with the purely command over here called
Brew which really helps us to do any
kind of package installations not only
Maven other packages also can be
installed pretty much with the help of
this executable now in order to see the
manual stuff what we really need to do
is that we need to actually clean this
uh specific installation so that I
should I will be able to show you the
manual installation also over here so
what I'm going to do is that I'm going
to run the command called
Brew uninstall Maven so that the maven
should be removed from your system so we
are just trying to remove the maven from
here and uh you can see that the maven
executable is not working as such over
here so which means that the maven is
uninstalled in this case but why I have
uninstalled here so that I should be
able to go ahead and download some
custom Maven over here in this one so I
have opened the browser here so I'll go
for the maven educatable so we'll go for
Maven download so that we should be able
to download a specific the executable
here so I'm going for this directory so
here uh 3.6.3 version same is available
here so I'm going to download the bin.z
which was the file we have so this is
also a kind of a Linux platform right so
that's the reason why uh here the tar
file should work perfectly fine so here
I'm going to the opt directory where we
can have all the optionals related
packages so if it is not there so I can
create a directory called slash opt
so I can log in with
root
so if you don't have the root access so
you can go for the applications in the
applications you can actually create a
directory called maven so here I can go
for me one
yeah
so here we will be downloading the VAR
file here so the tar.gun save file we
are downloading over here so I'll give
the path here so once the war file or
duplicate command I am using to do the
installation but sometimes the replicate
is not available so I can go for the
Brew install wget also if that package
is available on video the installation
will be done so we'll try to do the
installation using replicate so that we
will be able to get a tar file generated
or downloaded there are other ways also
you can download it from the browser
also yeah you can go to the browser and
here you can actually click and download
it and then you can transfer it locally
to this specific directory also so both
the possibilities are there but I'm just
trying to download the wget command so
that it will be easy for me to do the
setup and to do the download over here
so I'm going to run the same command
again
so it will download the tar file so this
is the tar file which is available over
here so I'm going to extract it over
here
so once the extraction is done so I'm
going to rename it like to Apache maven
so that I should not have any kind of
versioning or these kind of parameters
over here and the Apache dot uh Maven
hyphen the star file I'm trying to
remove as such over here so this is what
I have got as an end result over here
now this is the current directory in
which I have these uh applications and
these setups going forward over here so
if I run the mvn hyphen iPhone version
command
so that will not be giving me any kind
of output over here because uh still I
have extracted the tar file but that is
not the activity is not complete I have
to exactly set up some environment
variables so that I should be able to
run this mvn command so what I really
need to do over here is that we have to
export certain variables
application slash me one
Apache mav1 so this is the home
directory which I am trying to configure
over here and then next thing is that
path variable so I'm going to have we
are going to coordinate the path
variable with the folder so I'm going to
have the folder structure here so
the bin directory we have to provide so
I'm going to copy here and paste and
then I'm concatenate it with the bin
here so now my environment variables are
established so my mvn hyphen iPhone
version command as you can see here is
that uh you know it's being picked up
over here but it's saying that the
particular Java runtime is not available
so I can go for Java blue install Java
so that should be enough there to
install a Java package there so you can
see that it says that it's already
installed so and apps to date so that's
the reason why it's not able to do the
installation so I'm going to reinstall
open jdk
because what happens that when we do the
installation some environment variables
related to Java should be formatted or
should be extracted over here right so
as you can see that uh here it's saying
that if you want to really use the
executable of java you have to
concatenate the path like this so let's
run that and then we can see that the
particular executable of java will also
be
find out over here so Java hyphen
version showing that yes it's available
there and now my command
should be able to show me that yes it's
working fine the GDK was already
installed but the problem with that is
that since it's installed into a
particular location so you have to
actually override your path value so
that you should be able to see in that
directory and find out the Java
executable so that I have got by doing
the installation I got the command over
there in the output saying that this is
the installation which is done and now
you just have to extract or you have to
just you know put that bar directory
into the specified path variable and
that's how you got the maven and Java
both command lines working over here so
this is how you will be doing the maven
installations all together how the
overall installation of Maven and the
jdk really works on Mac operating system
now what exactly is in Maven repository
all about
so Maven repository is something which
is uh kind of a directory or it's kind
of a location where we have all the jar
files packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
jar files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the pump files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows Maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositives from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our specific Maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right now the local repository will be
primary present onto your PC that's the
way that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on to the Internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from remote repository it's
first downloaded into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and Central repository is refers to the
mayman rip Community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
and every dependency present on that
repository so Maven downloads the
repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they're needed or
whenever required all these dependencies
are cached locally from where it will be
referenced in the next or you know
whenever we want to refer that we will
be able to do that particular reference
easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories are Maven
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
foreign
now what are the basic concepts of Maven
here so some of the couple of basic
concepts which is present in Maven is
like for the first time we have the
project object model so project Palm
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular form
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so Maven is something
which search for the pump file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pump file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise the it will hold
there itself so this powerful is very
important because it will act as some
kind of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this specific XML file there and
according to that only it will function
or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the Java libraries which we
need in Enterprise into our particular
project so while working on the project
we may be having the dependency on
couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once this is a particular
information or these details are
referred so what will happen that uh we
need to download these specific
dependencies from the particular Maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then Maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then only it will go to the remote
or the central Repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugin cm then we have the build profile
so build profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven's build script
here
then with different uh build profiles
are added to the pump files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here then a build
profile helps in customizing the build
for the different environments so that
also we can perform as such while work
forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to design on that
particular Factor so these are something
which we need to take here or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the uh Maven
there so we have to use some couple of
Maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the bar file creating the jar
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so Maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh we know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have some specific goals
executed with the help of these build
plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in Maven what happens that uh
we'll let's talk about the basic
architecture of Maven here so the maven
executable when it's deployed so it
usually uh reads the palm.xml file which
is the build script here now once the
specific bounded XML file is being read
out so it will process the components it
will uh you know download or it will
process the dependencies plugins life
cycles phases and goals and even the
build profiles and uh if any kind of
interaction is required so it will try
to connect to the central repository or
remote repository and according to that
it will provide the information and
provide the details as such so mu and
repository is something which is very
important because it's ultimately trying
to connect to the maven repository and
try to achieve the various kind of
automation here so it's very important
because ultimately it's trying to help
us to go for the complete end-to-end
build automation when we'll go for a
specific Palm based build automation
so um Maven is going to read the
palm.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power XML
file and that dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then create and generate
a remote a report according to the
requirement and execute the life cycles
phases goals plugins
Etc so it will process the boundary XML
file then and whatever the plugins and
goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build
lifecycle is something which is a kind
of a collection of different steps here
and this is something which is followed
uh to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean day and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the beaver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds those these are the different
phases and these stages which we
normally follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific Maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of Maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache Maven helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here
right and Maven provides easy access to
all the required information so Maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the particular or built onto this
Jenkins or any kind of build tool there
right in Maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the prom file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific palm.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair right so let's talk
about the demo now so let's see that how
exactly we can go for this demo and we
can perform the various kind of
automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so Maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now I'm going to run a particular
command called mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will download some
of the binders there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so couple
of a particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so I am going to follow like five here
so I'll press five
then a group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like com dot simply learn so
that's a value which I'm providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact uh ID which
is there so version I am keeping the
same only so and uh yeah so package same
here
so I just want to create so I'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that our
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact ID you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pound.xml
file now this palm.xm file when I open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group ID
you want to follow so this is a group ID
this is the artifact ID so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the J unit dependencies added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular Maven project a
power.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the Target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of Jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the Target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is the way that how we can actually go
for a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable
welcome everyone to this topic in which
we are going to talk about that what
exactly is the different Maven interview
questions here now in this one we are
going to talk about what are the
different questions some couple of
questions we are going to go through and
we'll try to understand that what
exactly the answers are now uh let's
talk about the first question over here
so what exactly is in Maven here so
Maven is nothing but a kind of a popular
open Tool uh open source build tool
which is available there now before uh
Maven there were a couple of build tools
which was present like and and you know
a lot of other Legacy tools was present
there but after that Maven is something
which was released as an open source
tool and it really helps the
organization to uh automate some couple
of build processes and you know have
some particular mechanisms like build
publish and deploys off of different
different projects at once itself so
it's a very powerful tool which can
really help us to do the build
automation so we can integrate them with
the other tools like chain and you know
we can automate them we can schedule the
builds so a lot of various advantages we
can get with the help of this tool here
it's primary written in Java and it can
be used to build up various other kind
of projects also like c-sharp Scala Ruby
Etc so all these other typical tools can
also be built up with the help of this
tool so this tool is primedly uh used to
do the particular development and
management of the artifacts in the Java
based projects so uh for most of the
JavaScript projects nowadays this is the
default tool and it's already integrated
with the eclipse also so when you go for
a new weavon project automatically uh it
will be created for a Java project you
can use it for other languages also but
yes default choice of java of of the
Java programming language is Maven build
tool only now let's talk about next
question so what does the maven help
with so Maven Apache Maven helps to
manage all the processes such as build
process documentation release process
distribution deployment preparing the
artifact so all these tasks is being
primarily taken care by the Apache mav1
so this tool specifies the process of
project building it also increases the
performance of the project and the
overall building process so all these
things are something which is being
taken care by these specific Maven tool
here so it also uses the particular uh
you know it downloads the jar files of
the different dependencies for example
if your source code is dependent on some
of the Apache web service jar files or
some of the other third-party jar files
in that case you don't have to download
those jar files and keep in some
repository or keep it in some lib
directory you just have to mention the
dependency in the maven and that jar
file will be downloaded during the build
process and will be cached locally so
that's the biggest Advantage which we
get with Maven that you don't have to
take care of all these dependencies
anywhere into your Source Code system so
Maven provides easy access to all the
required information it helps the
developer to build the projects and
without you know even worrying about the
dependencies processes or different
environments or different because it's
in a kind of a tool which can be used in
any platform Linux or Windows so they
don't have to do any kind of conversions
so all they have to do is that they have
to just add new dependencies and that
should be updated into the pom file and
depending on that dependencies the
source code will be built up and they
don't have to refer any kind of third
party jar files so they don't have to
play with the class bars during the
build process so no customizations is
actually required with this one now the
next question is that what are the
different elements that Maven take case
off so there are different kind of
elements which is being taken care by
Maven so uh the these particular
parameters are elements are builts
dependencies reports distribution
releases and mailing list so these are
the typical different different uh
Elements which is being taken care by
the May 1 during the build process and
during the preparation of the builds
here so all these things you can they
can explore they can extract on that
part and they can fully understand that
how they can work on all these different
different processes now next question is
that what is the difference primary
difference between the and Maven first
of all both of them are primary used for
the Javas project so and is the older
version and Maven is something which was
launched after the ad here so and has no
formal conventions like so which can be
uh you know coded into the build.xml
file there but yes the maven has
convention so information is not
required as such in the palm.xml file
there so and is procedural whereas Maven
is declarative over here so and does not
have any kind of life cycle so it
depends on you that how you program the
and there but Maven is having a lot of
life cycles there which we can configure
we can utilize so the uh ant related
scripts are not reusable because you
cannot reuse it and you have to do some
kind of customizations in order to work
on that but yes Maven is not having much
of the project related any kind of
dependencies they can be easily reusable
there because there is nothing about the
palm.xml file it's just the artifact
name and the dependencies which is uh
something we can override or we can
change and then the same palm.xml file
we can reuse assets for the new project
also so that is where the reusability
comes into the picture now ant is a very
specific build tool so we don't have to
there is no plugins as such which is
available there you just have to code
everything that what build process you
want to prepare whereas in case of Maven
we have the concept of plugins which can
really help us to understand that how we
can make or use of these plugins so that
we can have the reusability implemented
so these are some of the differences
which is available there between the ant
and Maven here now next thing is that
what exactly isn't Palm file all about
so Palm file is nothing but it's kind of
a XML file which is available there and
it's have having all the information
regarding the project and the
configuration details so it primarily
used over here that how the
configuration needs to be done and how
the setup should be performed as such
here so power.xm file is the build
script which we prepare uh you can
prepare it uh using a particular
component or you can have a particular
mechanisms or if you feel that you want
to have some kind of setup so all these
things typically can be implemented can
be done with the help of pill tool so
build tools can be really helpful for us
to do the automations and it can really
help us to understand that how some
build processes we can automate with
simply with the help of palm.xml file
here so the developers usually put up
everything inside these uh dependencies
in the XML file here so this is the file
which is uh usually present in the home
directory it's in the current directory
so that once the build is triggered it
will be picked up from the directory and
according to the steps according to the
content of the palm.x1 file the build
will be processed or will be created
here now what I'll incorporate into the
pump file here so the different
components which is included into the
palm.xml file here is the dependencies
uh developers and contributors plugins
plugin configuration and resources so
these are the typical components which
is a part of a permode XML file which
can be uh same for a lot of projects you
can do some customization and then the
same pump file can be reused for the
other projects also now one of the
minimum requirement of the elements
which is there for a palm for Palm XML
file so without which the pound XML file
will not be validated and will will be
getting a kind of validation errors so
the minimum required elements are
project root model version so it should
be 4.0.0 the group ID of the project the
artifact ID of the project and the
version of the artifact these are the
minimum things which we want to Define
so that we can understand that what kind
of artifact we are trying to prepare or
we are trying to create here so these
are the minimum required Elements which
is required in the pound XML file
without which the validation of the pump
file will fail and the build will also
fail here
now what exactly is the mint uh with the
term called build tool so build tool is
an essential tool is a kind of a process
for building or compiling the source
code here so it's needed or it's
required for the below for generated
processes if you want to generate the
source code if you want to compile the
source code you want to generate the
source code you want to generate some
documentation from the source code you
want to compile the source code or you
want to package the source code whether
it's a jar file it's a war file or it's
a ER file so whatever the packaging mode
you want to select you will be able to
do it with the help of the particular
build tool here and if you feel that you
want to upload these particular
artifacts to the artifact tree whether
it's on remote machine or locally there
so that also you can do it with the help
of this particular build tools here so
build tools can be helpful in doing a
lot of activities for the Developers
now one of the different steps which is
involved to install Maven on Windows now
all you have to do is that you have to
just first of all download the DAR file
from the maven Apache Maven repository
there once that is done so what happens
that you have to set up some couple of
environment variables now if you
download the Java jdk using the exe file
in that case the Java underscore home
will be configured automatically but if
it is not available and you are not able
to run the Java command line in that
case you have to set up the Java
underscore home and then similarly for
me when you have to go for the maven
underscore home that particular variable
you have to configure now once that is
done all you have to do is that you have
to edit the path variable so the bin
directory of the maven extracted folder
you have to put it up into the path
variable and once that is done what will
happen that you will be able to check
the latest version the version of the
maven over there if it is like some old
version again you have to extract the
latest version and do the steps all
together again so these are some of the
ways that in which you can actually go
for the installation or the
configurations of Maven on the Windows
platform
now what are the different steps which
is involved for the installation of
Maven and Ubuntu so Ubuntu it's fine you
just download the package of java GDK
there once the jdk is installed over
there what you can do you can simply go
and say that yes I want to search for a
particular Maven package which is
available there so once the jdk is
installed all you have to do is that you
have to configure the Java underscore
home M3 underscore home may want to just
go home and the path variable once all
the path variables are something which
is configured then you will be able to
check the latest version like whether
it's a the version is correct or we are
getting the standard version over here
or not over here so that's the main
mechanism that how we will be able to
you know configure the maven on Ubuntu
km now what exactly is the command to
install the jar into the local
repository now sometimes what happens
that we are not able to fetch like uh
some dependencies not present on the uh
particular Central repository memo
repository or your artificial repository
in that case you have some third party
jar which we want to install locally
onto your repository so in that case we
can go for the uh but we can download
the jar file there and then we can run
the command called mvn install install
hyphen file and then we are giving the
path like hyphen D file where the path
of the file should be provided now once
that is done so what will happen that in
the local dot M2 directory these
specific artifact will be downloaded and
will be installed here so this is a
mechanism where you will be able to
configure or you will be able to set up
the artifacts locally the Java file
locally here in the local repository so
next question is that how do you know
that the version of the maven being used
here so the version of the maven is
pretty easy to calculate so all you have
to do is that you have to just go for
mvn and space hyphen iPhone version the
moment you do that it will let you know
that what jdk or what Java version you
are using and it will also show you that
what particular Maven version your going
to use here so all that details you will
be able to get with that particular
command here
now what exactly is the clean default
and site in variable here so these are
the build Cycles which is available
there in within Maven so these are the
built-in build Cycles so for clean what
happens that this life cycle will help
you to perform the project cleaning so
usually during the build there are some
files which is created into the target
directory so the clean life cycle is
essentially helping us to clean up all
that directory all that particular
Target directory and when we talk about
the specific default so default a
lifecycle handles the projector
deployment that is the default life
cycle and site is something which is uh
you know helpful for creating this site
documentation
you know it's kind of a life cycle which
is available there so clean default and
site other different life cycles which
can perform different different kind of
attributes or different tasks here next
question
what exactly is a maven repository so
Maven repository refers to the
directories of the package jar files
that contain metadata now the metadata
refers to the Palm files relevant to
each project so here you can able to get
your artifacts uh stored there you can
download these artifacts also during the
maven build if you put up that
dependency you will there are different
kind of repositories which is available
there one is the local repository one is
a remote repository and one is the
central repository so these are the
different typical type of repositories
which we have where we can store the
artifacts also and from where we can
download the artifacts also whenever
required now the first one is the local
repository so local repository refers to
the machine of the developers itself
where all the project related files are
stored there now whenever we work on the
uh particular Maven so there is an in
the home directory dot M2 folder is
created now usually whatever the
artifacts downloaded from artifactory or
from the maven repository it gets cached
locally there and once it is downloaded
next time it will not download the same
artifacts or the same dependency all
together again so this local repository
is something which is available locally
on the developers machine only so it
contains all the dependent jars which a
particular developer is downloading
during the maven build now remote
repositories refers to the repository
which is present on the server and uh we
from where we will be downloading the
particular dependencies so the when when
we are running the maven build on a
fresh machine so usually over there the
local repository does not exist so in
that case what happens that the dot M2
directory is empty but the moment you
run the build what will happen that the
artifacts or the dependencies will be
downloaded from the remote repository
and uh once it is done once it's
downloaded it will be added or it will
be downloaded cached locally there and
it will be uh helpful in the future run
so that will be considered as a local
Repository because all the artifacts all
the dependencies are downloaded there
and Central repository is something
which is known as the maven Community
where all the artifacts is available
there so usually we cache or we mirror
these Central repositories as our
particular remote repositories because
it could be a possibility that these
remote repositories are something which
we are hosting into our organization and
Central repository is something which is
available centrally for everyone to use
it so these are something you know some
kind of repositories where each and
every artifacts will be stored and
anyone will be able to have the access
to these uh particular artifacts here so
these artifacts are every artifice every
open source uh artifits is something
which is available over there to these
Central repositories now how does the
maven architecture really work here so
the maven architecture really works in
the three steps the very first step is
that it reads the palm.xml file here
that's the very first step second in it
downloads the dependencies defined in
the pound of XML file into the local
repository from the central or the
remote repository here once that is done
so it will uh you know create or
generate the reports according to the
life cycles which you have configured
whether it's a clean install site deploy
package or whatever the life cycle you
want to trigger you will be triggering
that particular life cycle and
corresponding to that the build or a
specific task will be performed so these
are the three steps in which the overall
build or any kind of execution of power
XML file really happens here now what
exactly is the maven build life cycle so
Maven life cycle isn't nothing but
collection of steps here that needs to
be uh followed for doing a proper build
of a project here so there are primary
three built-in Cycles which is available
there default which handles the project
deployment clean which handles the
project uh cleaning there and site which
handles the create version of the
project sites documentation so these are
the three primary built-in built Cycles
life cycles which is available as such
now so build life cycle has you know
different kind of phases or the stages
here because in the previous uh
particular slide we were talking about
but what are the different uh particular
build life cycles which is available
there but these are the different phases
like what are the different
step-by-steps executions like further
deep down which is available there
inside a specific Maven build life cycle
so here you can see that it's compiling
then the test compile test execution is
there then package integration test to
verify install and the lastly deploy
here so these are the different build
phases which is available as such over
here so what exactly is the command to
use to do a particular Maven side so mvn
side is something which is used to
create a maven site here now usually
whatever the artifacts is prepared that
will be prepared in the Target directory
so here also you will be able to see a
site directory which is available there
in the Target directory which you can
refer for the site documentations what
is the different conventions used while
main naming a project in May 1. so
usually it involves three components so
the full name of a project in Maven
includes first of all the group ID for
example count at Apache com dot uh
example so these are some of the uh
particular way that where you can
provide the group ID artifact ID can be
exact project name like Maven project or
whatever the project you are creating so
sample project example project so these
kind of things will be there in the
artifact ID and lastly is the version
like which version of your artifact you
want to prepare like 1.0.0 hyphen
snapshot
2.0.0 so like this information you are
providing that what particular version
you are trying to configure here now
let's move on to the intermediate level
where we will be having little bit more
complex quotients related to the maven
here now what exactly is in Maven
artifact now usually what happens that
when we do a build process as an end of
result of the build process we will get
some artifacts for example when and we
build a.net project so there we will be
able to have a exe or dll files as an
artifacts similarly in case of May 1
when we do a build process there we get
the different kind of artifacts like
depending on the packaging mode like jar
file War files or the ER files here so
these are something which is you know
getting generated during the build
process during the maven process and you
can store them into your local
repository or you want to push them to
the remote repository it's something
that totally depends on you so Maven is
a tool which can help you to create all
the artifacts whether it's a jar file
whether it's a VAR files or whether it's
a ER file here
and every artifact is having three
attributes the first one is the group ID
the artifact ID and a particular version
and that's how you will be able to
identify a full-fledged artifact as such
in Maven so Maven is not about only the
name of the Char file it's actually
referring to the attributes like crop ID
the artifact ID and the version of the
artifact here now what are the different
phases of the clean life cycle here so
clean is something which is being used
to clean the target directory so that a
fresh build can be triggered there so
there are three steps pretty clean clean
and post clean here so if you wish that
you want to override the particular life
cycle configurations and you want to run
some particular steps before the clean
activity so you can do it into the
pre-clean and if you want to do it like
some steps after clean then post clean
can be utilized now what are the
different phases of the site life cycle
so pre-site site poor site and site
deploy so these are the different phases
which is available there in the site
life cycle what is exactly we meant by
the maven plugin now this is the huge
difference between the ant and Maven
here because in and we were not having
this that much support of the plugins
and that's the reason why we had to deal
with all the build configurations so we
have to Simply put the overall build
process that how the build should be
triggered but that is not something
which is there in case of Maven in May 1
we have a lot of flexibility because we
can actually put up what exactly build
configurations we want to put here we
can put some features like important
features over here in Maven and these
plugins we can utilize for example I
want to perform a compilation now I
don't really want to do any kind of
configurations in this one so what I can
do is that I can simply use the
compilation plugin in May 1 and that can
really help me because I don't have to
unnecessarily write or rewrite the
configuration that how the compilation
should be done it's something which is
pre-configured or pre-written in this
plugin is that I can simply import the
plugin and I can do the build process or
the compilation process in a pretty
standard mode so I don't really have to
do any kind of workarounds with that and
simply with a small automations I will
be able to reach that how this Maven
plugins can be integrated into my palm
or XML file and I can desire or I can
have some particular procedures and some
straps executed there so that's the
biggest benefit which we really get with
the help of miven plugins now why
exactly the maven plugins are utilized
so to create a jar files to create the
war files to compile the code files to
perform the unit testing to create the
project documentation and to create the
project reports so there are variety of
things in which we can actually use this
Maven plugins through the Integrations
within the power XML file there so it's
all about the plugins you just import
the plugin and that desired activity
will be performed there now one of the
different type of plugins which is there
so you can have have either build
projects for performing the build
activities you can have some build
plugins for reporting plugins also there
which can be only generated or utilized
to generate the reports to process the
reports and do any kind of formatting or
any kind of processing on the reports
here so that is where the reporting
plugins are utilized now what is exactly
the difference between the convention
and the configuration in May 1. so
convention is in particular process when
the developers are not required to
create the build processes so
configuration is when you know the
developers are supposed to create the
build processes so the users do not have
to rectify the configuration in detail
and once the project is created it will
automatically create a structure so they
must specify every in case of
configuration you have to provide each
and every details so that's how the
configurations really happens because
you have to put every detail into the
power XML file and that's how the
particular configurations really work as
such so this is the huge difference
between the conventions and the
configurations here now so why exactly
said that Maven uses conventions over
the configuration so maybe it pretty
much does not puts any efforts like on
the particular developers that they have
to put each and every configuration so
there are some ready-made plugins which
is available there and pretty much we
are making use of that so that in such a
case we don't have to worry about the
executions and we will be able to pretty
much work on that so conventions like
Maven uses the conventions incident of
the configurations so the developers
does no they don't just have to create
the maven project the rest of the
particular structure will be taken gear
automatically so they are not uh you
know expecting that the developers
should be doing the configuration work
and everything should be taken care in
such a way that you just have to start
the things and rest of the things should
be taken care by the maven itself so
Maven will be responsible because the
due to the plugins it will be
responsible to set up the default
architecture the default folder
structures and all you have to do is
that you have to just place these scored
in the desired folder structure here so
that's something which you need to do as
in particular developers so what exactly
is the maven order of inheritance here
so the order of inheritance is the
settings CLI parameters parent form and
the project Palm which means that if you
have some configuration and settings
that will be the highest value then the
CLI parameters are there then the parent
Palm is there and then the project Palm
so this is the way that how the
particular parameters or the
configurations will be picked up by the
May one so that's the order so what does
the build life cycles and the phases
imply in the basic concept of Maven so
build life cycles consists of a sequence
of build phases and each build phase
consists of a sequence of goals when a
phase is run all the goals related to
that phase and its plugins are also
compiled so you will be able to have a
lot of particular goals which is
residing inside of phase there and
similarly life cycle is nothing but a
kind of a sequence of the different
phase so life cycle comes in the top
then it comes on the phases and then it
comes on the goals here now what is the
terminology called goal in case of Maven
the term a terminology goal refers to
the specific task that makes it possible
for the the project to be built and
organized so it's something which we can
run so it's a actual implementation
which is going on there for example in
the build process in the live build
phase I have a different goals like
clean install package deploy these are
the different typical goals which is
available there which I can execute into
the maven here so these are the
different goals like which we can
execute and which we can run during a
maven build next question is what is
exactly meant by the term dependencies
and the repositories in Maven here so
dependencies refer to the Java libraries
which we usually put up into the pound
or XML file there now what happens that
sometimes our source code is requiring
some jar files like a secondary jar
files for performing the build process
so instead of downloading it and storing
it into the class path for during the
build process we just have to specify
the dependency of that artifact what
dependency we need to put and once that
dependency is put up there we will be
able to have that jar file downloaded
and cached into the local repository
during the maven build project now if
the dependencies are not present into
your local repository then Maven will
try to download it from the central
repository and again if it is not a uh
you know it's something which is
available which is downloaded from the
central repository then it will be
cached locally into the local repository
so that's a cycle which is being
implemented and utilized during this
process
now what exactly isn't snapshot in Maven
so snapshot refers to the version
already available in the moment report
repository it signifies the latest
development copy that's what we do with
the case of snapshot here so Maven
checks for a new version of snapshot in
the remote repository for every new
build so during the build process like
uh you know a new snapshot version is
being downloaded and the snapshot is
updated by the data service team which
with updated source code every time to
the repository for each Maven page so
snapshot is something which we will be
using like very frequently we will be
updating to that and frequently we will
be updating the version to that and we
will try to explore and we'll try to do
the modifications now what are the
different type of projects available in
Maven so there are thousands of java
projects which you know can be utilized
or we can be implemented by my one here
so this helps the as the user that they
as they no longer have to remember every
configurations to set up particular
project for example spring boot spring
MVC spring boot Etc these are the
different projects which is already
available in Maven so most of the we
have already discussed that for the jar
based projects maybe something which is
you know considered as by default so a
lot of organizations are actually using
it for you know storing or utilizing it
for the particular Maven project now
what exactly is the maven uh archetype
over here so Maven octave refers to a
maven plugin that is uh entitled to
create a for a project structure as per
its template these archetypes are just
project templates that are generated by
Maven when any new project is created
there so this is something which we are
using so that we will be able to create
a fresh new projects right so let's go
on to the advanced level of this Maven
questions now what exactly is the
command create a new project based on an
archive type so mvn archetype generate
is used to create a new Java Project
based on the archetype now this will
take a of some parameters from as an end
user from you and depending on that
parameters it will create the bound.xml
file it will create the source
directories inside that main Java test
all these different couple of
directories relative structures will be
automatically created now why we require
this command so that if you are going to
create a project from scratch from the
from the day one this command will help
you to have all the folder structures
created and then further on you can put
up your source code and those files as
such in this folder structure so that's
how is the mechanism that we will be
able to see that how the setup can be
performed really over here now what does
mavenclean implies now movement clean is
a plugin that suggests that it's going
to clean the files and directories there
so whenever we do a build process
usually in the Target directory we have
some class files some jar files or
whatever the generated source code which
is available that will be present in the
docker directory so the maven clean is
something which is available which is
going to clean all these directories and
why we are doing this directly structure
cleanup so that we will be able to do a
fresh uh build process and there should
not be any kind of issues as such over
here so that's the main reason why we
are looking forward for this particular
mechanism or for this particular changes
as such here now so what exactly isn't
build profile all about so build
profiles refers to the set of
configurations uh where we can have like
typically two different kind of build
processes there so if you feel that the
same pump detection file you can use you
want to run for different different
particular configurations so that you
will be able to do pretty much with the
help of this component so build profile
is used to do a customization processes
so that you will be able to have the
process and you will be able to perform
the configurations and the setups all
together there so that's a very
important aspect to be considered that
which we need to uh discuss when we talk
about the build profile so build profile
whenever you feel that you want to do
some customizations and you want to
proceed with the setup so that's where
it's utilized next thing is that what
are different type of build profiles
which is available there so the build
profiles can be done on for a particular
project like per project you can do you
can uh even do the build profiles in the
settings.xml file also and if you feel
that you want to do it into the global
settings.xm file so that also you can do
as such over here so there are different
ways in which you can do the
customization and once the customization
is done you will be able to have the
different uh ways of doing the setups
and the configurations over there so
what exactly is meant by the uh
particular system dependencies here so
let's talk about that also so system
dependencies refers to the particular
mechanisms where we feel that uh how the
dependencies should be you know present
there so that is something which is
having a scope of system there so these
depends senses are commonly used to help
Maven know the dependencies that is
being provided by the jdk system
dependencies are mostly used to resolve
the dependencies on the artifacts that
are provided by the jdk so these
dependencies are somewhat which is being
utilized and used over here so that we
will be able to implement and go ahead
through the system dependencies what is
the reason for using an optional
dependency here so optional dependencies
are used to decrease the transitive
burden of some libraries so what happens
that when you download an artifact when
you put up a dependency so it could be a
possibility that some dependencies as in
particular optional can also be
downloaded now these are not always
required but yes sometimes what happens
that these are downloaded so that you
don't have to put each and every uh
artifact or dependency into the pound or
XML file for example you're trying to
download some Apache tool and with that
some like three four jar files or three
four another dependencies are also
getting downloaded now if you are using
that dependencies that totally create
because you don't have to put that a
list or that entry in the dependency
list in the pound or XML file and that
can really save your time but if you
feel that you don't want to have them
and you these are the optional ones and
you really want to get rid of that so
that also you can exclude while
downloading any kind of dependency so
these are the optional ones which
depending on your requirement you can
utilize you can process and if you feel
that you don't want to get it you won't
want to process it you can simply ignore
it and you can get rid of that also now
what is the dependency scope and how
many type of dependencies scope are
there so there are different type of
dependencies course which is there which
is used on each and every stage of the
build here so compile provided runtime
test system import these are the
different kind of dependency Scopes
which we have using which we can Define
that when exactly we want to go ahead
for a specific build process so
depending on your required comment you
can explore all these build Scopes and
you can get benefits out of that what is
exactly as intransitive dependency in
May 1. so Maven avoids the need to find
out and specify libraries that our own
dependencies required by including the
transitive dependencies automatically so
transitive dependencies says that if he
depends if x depends on Y and Y depends
on Z then X depends on Y and both there
so which means that you are not
depending on one artifact you also need
the Z artifact there with the Y artifact
so that is what you need to do so that
you will get both the dependencies there
because this is normal that if you are
trying to download some particular
artifacts or download some dependency
and that dependency is also dependent on
some other artifact or some other Char
file then you have to include both of
them so this is something which you will
be able to get so that you can easily
download all these dependent jar files
also and the maven build can be success
how can a maven build profile can be
activated so moving build profile can be
activated through different ways so
explicitly using the command uh command
line you can talk about that which
profile you want to execute through
Maven settings you can do uh based on
environment parameters OS settings and
present and missing files so these are
the different ways in which you can
actually activate that which particular
profile you want to have so profiles
configurations can also be saved in
various situations and various files and
from there you will be able to refer
that which file you want to refer as
such now what is meant by the dependency
exclusion the exclusion is used to
exclude any transitive dependency
because you never know that if you are
trying to put up a dependency of entry
in the power X1 file that artifact is
also further dependent on another
artifact so in order to feel in order to
see that you want to exclude that
dependent artifact which is being
automatically downloaded that also we
can exclude with the help of exclusion
so you can avoid the transitive
dependency with the help of dependency
exclusions here so what exactly is in
Mojo So Mojo is nothing but Maven plane
old Java object here so it's an
executable goal in Maven and a plug-in
refer to the distribution of such Moses
so Moses enable the maven to extend its
functionality that already is not
founded in so it's kind of an extension
which is there and using this we can get
some additional benefits and some
executions over there so what is the
command to create a new project based on
a hard drive so again archive is
something which we normally use to
create the new projects now you can give
the parameters in the command itself or
you want it to in in kind of an
interactive mode where it will take the
parameters from the end user and
according to that the project will be
created onto hard drive or onto server
wherever you wish you want to create you
can create a new project
so explain about the maven settings.xml
file so Maven settings.xml file contains
the elements that are used to define
that how the maven execution should be
there so there are different uh settings
like local remote Central all these
different repositories are configured as
such over here now in this case what
happens that uh usually the
configurations are done in such a way
that it can you know go for the
executions it can go for the build
process and the complete executions can
be involved and can be achieved as a
chair so all these executions are
something which we can really perform
and uh here we can put some credentials
how to connect to the remote repository
how to connect to remote repository all
that stuff is something which we talk
about over here what exactly is and
meant by term super bomb here so super
form refers to the default form of Maven
so the moms of Maven can derive from so
it's nothing but a reference to a parent
form which is available there that is
the Super Pawn so if you define some
dependencies in that super form
automatically the uh child form will
also be able to inherit all those
dependencies so we can put some
executions like we can put some
configuration in the super pump so that
if multiple projects are going to refer
that they should be able to refer that
easily so that's the reason why we
primarily use the Super Pawn so that we
can have the execution some processes
put up over there and all the other
projects should be effort to refer or
inherit from there so where exactly the
dependencies are stored so dependencies
are stored like in different locations
like you have the local repository
remote repository is there local
repositories on the local developers
machine and remote repository something
which is available on a server in form
of artifactory now let's talk about the
Cradle installation because this is a
very important aspect to be done because
when we are doing the installation we
have to download the Cradle executables
right so let's see that what are the
different steps is involved in the
process of the Gradle installation
so when we talk about the Gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
Java is installed now if the Java is not
installed so you can go to the open jdk
or you can go for the Oracle Java so you
can do the installation of the jdk on
your system so jdk8 is something we can
most commonly use nowadays so you can
install that once the Java is downloaded
and installed then you have to do the
Gradle uh download cradle there now once
the Gradle binaries are executable uh or
the user file gets downloaded so you can
add the environment variables and then
you can validate if the critical
installation is working fine as expected
not so we will be doing the Gradle
installation into our local systems and
uh into the windows platform and we'll
see that how exactly we can go for the
installation of cradle and we'll see
that what are the different version we
are going to install here so let's go
back to the system and see that how we
can go for the Gradle installation so
this is the website of the jdk of a Java
Oracle Java now here you have different
jdk so from there you can do whatever
the option you want to select you can go
with that so jdk8 is something which is
most commonly used nowadays like it's
most comfortable or compatible version
which is available so in case you want
to see that if the jdk is installed into
your system all you have to do is that
you have to just say like Java hyphen
version and that will give you the uh
put it whether the Java is installed
into your system or not so in case my
system the Java is installed but if you
really want to do the installation you
have to download the jdk installer from
this website from this Oracle website
and then you can proceed further on that
part now once the jdk is installed so
you have to go for the Cradle
installation because Gradle is something
the which will be performing at the
build automations and all that stuff so
you have to download the bindies like a
zip file probably in which we have the
executables and all and then we have to
have have some particular environment
variables configured so that we will be
able to have the System modified over
there so right now we have got like the
prerequests as in Java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables so
uh in order to download the latest
Gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like uh you want
to go for 6.7 now it's there having like
binary only or complete we'll go for the
binary only is because we don't want to
have the source we just want the
binaries and the executables now it's
getting downloaded it's around close to
100 MB of the installer which is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same path we need
to configure into the environment
variable so that in that way we will be
able to see that how the uh Gradle
executables will be running and it will
give the complete output to us over here
in this case so it may take some time
and once the uh particular modifications
and the download is done then we have to
extract it and once the extraction is
done so we will be able to go back and
uh have some particular version or have
the configurations established over
there so that let's just wait for some
time and then we will be continuing with
the environment variables like this one
so once the installation and the
extraction is done now we just have to
go to the downloads where this one is
downloaded we have to extract it now
extraction is required so that we can
have the setup like we can set up this
path into our environment variables and
once the path is configured and
established we will be able to start
further on that part on the execution so
meanwhile these files are getting
started let's see so we already the
folder structure over here and we will
see like we will give this path here
there is two environment variables we
have to configure one is the Gradle
underscore home and one is the
um in the path variable so we'll copy
this path here so meanwhile this is
getting a
started we can save our time and we can
go to the environment variable so we can
right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables
now here we have to give it like cradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the griddle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry in this one we will be putting
up till the pin directory here because
the capital executable should be there
when I am running the Gradle command so
these two variables I have to configure
then okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like CMD
Java iPhone version to check the version
of the Java and then the Gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see to see check the version of the
Gradle which is installed and now you
can see that it saves that 6.7 version
is being installed over here in this
case so that's the way that how we are
going to have the Cradle installation
performed into our particular system and
in this one uh we will be also working
on some demos and some Hands-On to
understand that how we can make use of
Gradle for performing the build activity
so let's begin with the the first
understanding that what exactly is
incredible all about
now Gradle is in kind of a bell tool
which can be used for the build
automation performance and it can be
used for various programming languages
primarily it's being used for the Java
based applications it's some kind of
build tool which can help you to see
that how exactly automatically you can
prepare the builds you can perform the
automations earlier we used to do the
build activity from the eclipse and we
used to do it manually right but with
the help of this build tool we are going
to do it like automatically without any
manual efforts as such here they're not
like a lot of activities which we will
be doing during the build process
primarily there are different activities
like compilations linkage packaging
these are the different tasks which we
performed during the build process so
that we can understand that how the
build can be done and we can perform the
automations uh this uh process also it's
kind of standardized because again if
you want to automate something standards
or a standard process is something which
we require for that before we been going
ahead with that part so that's the
reason why we are getting this build
tool because this build tool helps us to
do a standardization process to see that
how the standards can be met and how we
can proceed further with that part
also it's something which can be used to
variety of languages programming
languages Java is the primary language
for which we use the Gradle but again
other languages like Scala Android CC
plus plus Ruby these are some of the
languages for which we can use the same
tool now it's actually using like it's
referring to as in Trophy based domain
specific language rather than XML
because ant and Maven these are the XML
based build tools but this one is not
that dependent on XML it's using The
Groovy based domain specific language
DSL language is being used here right
now again it's something which can be
used to do the build it can further on
be used to perform the test cases
automations also there and then further
on you can deploy to the artifactory
also that okay I want to push the
artifacts to the artifactory so that
also that part also you can get it done
over here so uh primary this tool is
known for doing the build automations
for the big and large projects the
projects in which the source code the
amount of source code and the efforts is
more so in that case this particular
tool makes sense now griddle includes
both the pros of Maven and ant but it
removes the drawbacks or whatever the
issues which we face during these two
build tools so it's helping us to remove
all the cons which we face during the
implementation of ant and Maven and
again again all the pros of ADD and
Maven is implemented with this cradle
tool
now let's see that why exactly this
griddle is used because that's a very
valid question that what is the activity
like what is the reason why we use the
Gradle because
um the first one is that it resolves
issues based on other build tools that's
a primary reason because we all already
having the tools like Maven and and
which is available there but primarily
this griddle tool is something which is
removing all the issues which we are
facing with the implementation of other
tools so these issues are getting uh
removed as such second one is that it
focuses on maintainability performance
and flexibility so it's giving the focus
on that how exactly we can manage the
big large projects and uh we can have
flexibility that what different kind of
approaches I want to build today I want
to build in different ways tomorrow the
source code modifies gets added up so I
have the flexibility that I can change
this build script so I can perform the
automations so a lot of flexibility is
available which is being supported by
this tool and then the last one is like
it provides a lot of features a lot of
plugins now this is one of the uh
benefit which we get in the case of
Maven also that we get a lot of features
but again when we talk about cradle then
it provides a lot of plugins like let's
say that normally in a build process we
do the compilation of the source code
but sometimes let's say that we want to
build an angular or a node.js
application now in that case we may be
involved in running some command line
executions some command line commands
just to make sure that yes we are
running the commands and we are getting
the output so there are a lot of
features which we can use like uh there
are a lot of plugins which is available
there and we will be using those plugins
in order to go ahead and in order to
execute those builds process and doing
the automations now let's talk about the
cradle and Maven because again when we
talk about mav1 like it was like
something which was primary used for the
Java but again when we are talking about
cradle so again it's just uh being used
primary for the Java here but what is
the reason that we prefer Gradle over
the create Mi one so what are the
different reason for that let's talk
about that part because this is very
important we need to understand that
what is the reason that Gradle is
preferred as a better tool for the Java
as compared to Maven when we talk about
for the build automation name
now the first one is that the Gradle
using The Groovy DSL language domain
specific language whereas the maven is
considered as in project management tool
which is uh creating the palms or XML
file format files so it's being used for
the Java project but XML format is being
used here and on the other hand griddle
is something which is not using the XML
formats and whatever the build scripts
you are creating that is something which
is there in the groupie based DSL
language and on the other hand in the
Palm we have to create the xmls
dependencies whatever the attributes you
are putting up in the May one that's
something which is available there in
the format of XML the overall goal of
the griddle is to add functionality to a
project whereas the goal of the maven is
to you know to complete a project phase
like to work on different different
project phase like compilation test
executions uh then uh packaging so then
deploying to artifactory so these are
all different phases which is available
there into the maven but on the other
hand griddle is all about about adding
the functionality that how you want to
have some particular features added up
into the build scripts in griddle there
are like we usually specify that what
are the different tasks we want to
manage so different different tasks we
can add up into the case of Gradle and
we can override those tasks also in case
of Maven it's all about the different
phases which has been happening over
here and it's in sequence manner so
these phases happens in the sequence
order that how exactly you can build up
the sequence there but in case of
griddle you can have your own tasks
custom tasks also and you can disrupt
the sequence and you can see that how
the different steps can be executed in a
different order so Maven is something
which is a phase mechanism there but
Gradle is something which is according
to the features or the flexibilities now
griddle works on the tasks whatever the
task you want to perform you uh it works
directly on those tasks there on the
other hand uh Maven is something does
not have any kind of inbuilt cache so
every time you're running the build so
separate uh things or the plugins and
all this information gets loaded up
which takes definitely a lot of time on
the other hand Gradle is something which
is uh using its own internal cache so
that it can make the bills a little bit
faster because it's not something which
is doing the things from the scratch
whatever the uh things is already being
available in the cache so it's just pick
that part and from there it will proceed
further on the build Automation and
that's the reason why cradle performance
is much faster as compared to Maven
because it uses some kind of a cache in
there and then helps to improve the
overall performance now let's talk about
the Gradle installation because this is
a very important aspect to be done
because when we are doing the
installation we have to download the
Cradle executables right so let's see
that what are the different steps is
involved in the process of the critical
installation
so when we talk about the Gradle
installation so there are primary four
steps which is available the very first
one is that you have to check if the
Java is installed now if the Java is not
installed so you can go to the open jdk
uh or you can go for the Oracle Java so
you can do the installation of the jdk
on your system so jdk8 is something we
can uh most commonly use nowadays so you
can install that once the Java is
downloaded and installed then you have
to do the Cradle uh download cradle
there now once the Gradle boundaries are
executable uh or the user file gets
downloaded so you can add the
environment variables and then you can
validate if the Gradle installation is
working fine as expected not so we will
be doing the Gradle installation into
our local systems and uh into the
windows platform and we'll see that how
exactly we can go for the installation
of cradle and we'll see that what are
the different version we are going to
install here so let's go back to the
system and see that how we can go for
the Gradle installation so this is the
website of the jdk of a Java Oracle Java
now here you have different jdk so from
there you can do whatever the option you
want to select you can go with that so
jdk8 is something which is most commonly
used nowadays like it's most comfortable
or compatible version which is available
so in case you want to see that if the
jdk is installed into your system all
you have to do is that you have to just
say like Java hyphen version and that
will give you the output at whether the
Java is installed into your system or
not so in case my system the Java is
installed but if you really want to do
the installation you have to download
the jdk installer from this website from
this Oracle website and then you can
proceed further on that part now once
the jdk is installed so you have to go
for the Cradle installation because
Gradle is something the which will be
performing at the build automations and
all that stuff so you have to download
the binders like the zip file probably
in which we have the executables and all
and then we have to have have some
particular environment variables
configured so that we will be able to
have the System modified over there so
right now we have got like the
prerequests as in Java version installed
now the next thing is that we have to
install or download the executables so
uh in order to download the latest
Gradle distribution so you have to click
on this one right now over here there
are different options like you want to
go for 6.7 now it's they're having like
binary only or complete we'll go for the
binary only is because we don't want to
have the source we just want the
binaries and the executables now it's
getting downloaded it's around close to
100 MB of the installer which is there
now we have to just extract into a
directory and then the same path we need
to configure into the environment
variable so that in that way we will be
able to see that how the uh Gradle
executables will be running and it will
give the complete output to us over here
in this case so it may take some time
and once the uh particular modifications
and the download is done then we have to
extract it and once the extraction is
done so we will be able to go back and
uh have some particular version or have
the configurations established over
there so that let's just wait for some
time and then we will be continuing with
the environment variables like this one
so once the installation and the
extraction is done now we just have to
go to the downloads where this one is
downloaded we have to extract it now
extraction is required so that we can
have the setup like we can set up this
path into our environment variables and
once the path is configured and
established we will be able to start
further on that part on the execution so
meanwhile these files are getting
started let's see so we already the
folder structure over here and we will
see like we will give this path here
there is two environment variables we
have to configure one is the Gradle
underscore home and one is the
um in the path variable so we'll copy
this path here so meanwhile this is
getting a
started we can save our time and we can
go to the environment variable so we can
right click on this one properties
in there we have to go for the advanced
systems settings
then environment variables
now here we have to give it like cradle
underscore home now in this one we will
not be going giving it till the bin
directory so that only needs to be there
where the griddle is extracted so we'll
say okay
and then we have to go for the path
variable where we will be adding up a
new entry in this one we will be putting
up till the pin directory here because
the Cradle executable should be there
when I'm running the Gradle command so
these two variables I have to configure
then okay okay
and okay
so this one is done so now you have to
just open the command prompt and see
that whether the execution or the
commands which you're running is is
completely successful or not so
meanwhile it's extracting all the
executables and all those things it will
help us to understand that how the whole
build process or how the build tools can
be integrated over there now once the
extraction is done so you have to run
like CMD
Java iPhone version to check the version
of the Java and then the Gradle
underscore version is what you're going
to see check the version of the Gradle
which is installed and now you can see
that it saves that 6.7 version is being
installed over here in this case so
that's the way that how we are going to
have the Cradle installation performed
into our particular system so let's go
back to the content let's talk about the
Cradle Core Concepts here now in this
one we are going to talk about what are
the different Core Concepts of cradle
are all about the very first one is the
projects here now a project represents a
item to be performed over here to be
done like deploying an application to a
staging environment performing some
build so Gradle is something which is
required uh the projects
um the Gradle project which you prepare
is not having multiple tasks which is
available there which is configured and
all these tasks all these different
tasks needs to be executed into a
sequence now sequences again is a very
important part because again if the
sequence is not meant properly then the
execution will not be done in a proper
order so that's the very important
aspect here
tasks is the one in which is a kind of
an identity in which we will be
performing a series of steps these tasks
may be like compilation of a source code
preparing a jar file preparing a web
application archive file or ER file also
we can have like in some tasks we can
even publish our artifacts to the
artifact we so that we can store those
artifacts into a shared location so
there are different ways in which we can
have this uh particular tasks executed
now build scripts is the one in which we
will be storing all this information
what are the dependencies what are the
different tasks we want to refer it's
all going to be present in the
build.gradle file there build.gradle
file will be having the information
related to what are the different
dependencies you want to download and
you want to store there so all these
things will be a part of the build
Scripts
now let's talk about the features of
cradle what are the different features
which we can use in case of cradle here
there are different like type of
features which is available there so
let's talk about them one by one so the
very first one over here is the high
performance then high performance is
something which we can see that we
already discussed that in case you are
using a large projects so Gradle is
something which is in better approach as
compared to Maven because of the high
performance which we are getting it uses
an internal cache which makes sure that
you are using like you are doing the
builds faster and that can give you a
higher performance over there second one
is the support it provides the support
so it yes definitely provides a lot of
support on how you can perform the belts
and it's being a latest tool which is
available there so the support is also
quite good in terms of how you want to
prepare the build how you want to
download the plugins different plugin
supports and the dependencies uh
information also there next one is
multi-project build software so using
this one you can have multiple projects
in case in your repository you have
multiple projects say so all of them can
be easily built up with the help of this
particular tool so it supports multiple
projects to be built up using the same
Gradle project and Gradle scripts so
that support is also available with this
cradle a build tool incremental builds
are also something which you can do with
the help of cradle so if you have done
only the incremental changes and you
want to perform only the incremental
build so that can also be possible with
the help of a griddle here the uh build
scans so we can also perform the build
scans so we can use some Integrations
with sonar Cube and all where we can
have the scans done to the source code
on understand on how the build happens
or how the source code really happens on
there so that code scan or the build
scans can also be performed with this
one and then it's a familiarity with
Java so for Java it's something which is
considered as in by default not even
Java in fact Android which is also using
the Java programming language is using
the particular cradle over here so that
the build can be done and it can gain
benefits out of that so in in all the
manners in all the different ways it's
basically helping us to see that how we
can make sure that this tool can help us
in providing a lot of features and that
can help us to make a reliable build
tool for our Java based projects or any
other programming based project here
right now let's see that how we can
invert a Java project with a griddle
here and for that we have to go back and
readily something which is already
installed we just have to create a
directory where we can have like how we
can perform some executions we can
prepare some build scripts and we can
have a particular execution of a Gradle
build happened over there so let's go
back to the machine okay so we are going
to open the terminal here and we'll see
that how we can create it so first of
all I have to create a directory
structure let's say that we'll say like
Gradle
hyphen project now once the project is
created so we can go inside this
directory so to create some critical
related projects and preparing the files
now uh in this one we'll let's first
create a particular one so we will be
saying like VI build dot Gradle so in
this one we are going to put like a do
plugins we are going to use so we are
going to say like apply
frogging
Java and then we are going to say like
apply
for login
application
so these two plugins we are going to use
and when we got this file over here in
this one so it shows like build.gradle
which is available there in this case so
two these files are available now if you
want to learn like you know what are the
different tasks so you can run like
griddle tasks command over there so
Gradle task will help you know that what
are the different tasks which is
available over here by processing the
build scripts and all so um this will
definitely help you to understand on
giving you the output so here all the
different tasks are being given and it
will help you to understand that what
are the different tasks you can
configure and you can work over here
just like jar files clean and all that
stuff build compile then uh in it is
there then all these different
executions assemble then Java doc then
build then check test all these
different tasks are there and if you
really want to run the Gradle build so
you can run like Gradle clean to perform
the clean activity because right now you
are doing like if a build so before that
you can have a clean and then you can
run a specific command or you can run
The Griddle clean build which will
perform the cleanup also and it will at
the same time will have the build
process also performed over there so
build and clean up both will be executed
over here and what is the status whether
it's the success or the failure that
will be given back to you now in this
case in the previous one if you see that
when you run the clean the Cradle clean
it was only running one task but when
you go for the build uh process when you
run the Cradle clean build it's going to
give you a much more information in fact
you can also give me uh further
information like you can have the hyphen
iPhone Info flag also there so that if
you want to get the details about the uh
different uh tasks which we which is
being executed over here so that also
you're going to get over here in this
one so you just have to put like hyphen
iPhone Info and then all these steps
will be given back to you that how these
tasks will be executed and the response
will be there so that's the way that how
you can provide a pretty much simple
straightforward project in form of
cradle which can definitely help you to
run some couple of Gradle commands and
then you can understand that what are
the basic commands you can run and how
the configurations really works on there
right let's go back to the main content
right now let's move on to the next one
so in the next one we are going to see
that how we can prepare a griddle build
project in case of eclipse now we are
now using the local system we are not
directly creating the folders and the
files here we are actually using the
eclipse for performing the creating a
new Gradle project over here so let's
move on that part okay so now the
eclipse is open and I have opened in
this one the very first thing is that we
have to do the Gradle plugin
installation so that we can create new
projects on cradle and then we have to
configure the path that's how the Gradle
plugin can be configured on the previous
uh preferences and all that stuff and
then we will be doing the build process
so the very first thing is that we have
to go to the eclipse Marketplace
in there we have to search for griddle
so once the search is done
it will show us the plugins related to
cable so we have to go for build ship
Gradle integration so we'll click on the
install
it will proceed with installation it
will download it in some cases maybe
it's part of the eclipse as an uh in the
ID so you can go to the install Tab and
you can see that also that if this
plugin is already installed or not but
in this case we are installing it and uh
once the installation is done we just
have to restart the uh specific uh once
we have to restart this Eclipse so that
the changes can be reflected
so it's downloading
it's downloading the Cradle here and
once that is installed we will be able
to use it over here in this case in this
scenario so we have to just wait for
that part so still downloading the jar
files so once the jar file is done it's
now over the areas and download it so
after that we will be able to proceed
further on that download aspect so it's
going to take some time to download it
and once it's done we will be able to
proceed further now once the progress is
done so it's asking us for the restart
now so before that uh we just have to
click on restart now and then the
eclipse will be restarted all together
again here so you can do it manually or
you can go for that options you just
require a restart so that the new
changes can be reflected over here so
the plugins can be activated and can be
referenced here now we have to just uh
put up like the you know the
configuration where we can have the
system so we can go for the Gradle
configuration so we can go for Windows
and then preferences
now in this case we have to go for the
uh for the ones in which the Cradle
option is available there so cradle is
what we are going to select now user
home the Gradle user home is what we
need to use right so you want to go for
the Gradle you want to go for local
installation so so all these options you
can use you can if if you go for the
griddle wrapper then it will be
downloading the Gradle locally and it is
going to use the Cradle W or griddlew
dot bat file but if you already have an
installation locally so you can prefer
that also right now in the previous demo
we have already got the Gradle uh
extracted so we just have to go for the
downloads in the downloads already
Gradle is available so we are going to
select that part here so this is what we
are going to select
right so this represents that this is
the directory structure in which we are
having the mechanism so you can either
go for the build scan so you can select
the build scan also so once this is
enabled then all the projects will be
scanned and will be you know published
and uh it's in kind of an additional
option which is available if you really
want to disable it you can disable it
also and you can go with this
configuration so
so uh this is where the particular
Gradle folder is being put over here in
this case and then we have to just click
on apply
and we just have to click on apply and
close so with this one the particular
execution is done now we will be going
for the project creation so you can
right click over here or you can go to
the file also so here we are going to go
for the job project and in this we are
going to have a Gradle project so Gradle
project is what we are going to create
here
and next
so we are going to say like cradle
project
and then next
so once that is done so finish
so uh with this one when you create the
project so what will happen that uh
automatically there will be a folder
structure will be available there right
and uh there are some Gradle scripts
which will also be created there so we
will be doing the modifications there
and we'll see that how the uh particular
Gradle build script looks like and how
we can we will be adding some couple of
uh selenium related dependencies and
we'll see that how we can have more and
more dependencies added and what will be
the impact of those dependencies on the
overall project so that also it's very
important aspect to be considered so let
this processing be happen over there
just creating and uh some plugins and
binaries are getting installed and
getting downloaded so we'll see that
once the project is imported completely
executed over here and got created we
can extract that now if you see here the
particular option is available about the
Gradle tasks so you can extract it also
and you will be able to know that what
are the different tasks which is
available there let's see that in the
build they are running like build these
are the different tasks which is
happening inside the build process so
gradual executions will be also
available over here in this case and
greater tasks will be different it will
be represented over here in this one so
you just have to extract on the Gradle
project okay so this is the library
which is available now uh what happens
that uh you will be able to have like
settings.gradle in this one you will be
able to have like okay Gradle hyphen
project is something which is available
there in this one so that's what we're
being aren't referring then we have over
here as in these folder structures which
is created like Source main Java this is
the one source test Java is the one
which is available as an on the folder
structure and so test resources are also
available here so the main source main
resources are also available now in this
case what happens that these are the
dependencies project and external these
are the different dependencies are
available there so let's see let's add a
dependency over here in this one in the
build.gradle script and see that how we
can do that if we open build.gradle file
so you can see that these dependencies
are there like test implementation junit
is available there right and then we
have implementations of this one which
is available now these jar files which
you put up it will automatically be
added up as in part of this one as in
part of the uh particular dependencies
over here and which means that you don't
have to store them as a now within the
repository and automatically they can be
happened over there so let's open a
dependency page so we will be going to a
mean repository where we will be opening
a dependency link so this is the
dependency link here so selenium hyphen
Java is available and it can give you
the dependency for all the different
options now we have for Maven this is
the one and frogadle this is the one
here so we have to just copy this one
and we have to use it as a dependency so
this is the group and this is the name
and the version which we are using here
now we have copied this one so we will
go back to the Eclipse so here we have
to just put that dependency
and we have to save it so uh this is
something which is providing like
selenium dependencies which is available
so now we have to just refresh the
project so right click over here then
you will be able to see the options in
the grader saying that refresh Gradle
project now once the moment you do that
so you will be able to do like for the
first time maybe it will take some time
to download all the dependencies which
is related to selenium but after that
you will be able to select the
dependencies will be simply added up
over here in this case so you can see
that all the selenium related
dependencies are added up for any reason
if you comment these ones
and you say like
synchronize again
so you will see that all the
dependencies which you are adding up
from this selenium represent uh from the
selenium perspective will be gone back
again
so this is the way that how you can keep
on adding the dependencies which is
required for preparing your bill for
your source code and from there you will
be able to proceed further on the
execution part so that's the best part
about this cradle here so that's the way
that how we are going to prepare a
Gradle project within the eclipse and
now you can keep on adding like the
source code in this one and that's the
way that how the code base will be added
up over here right so that's the way
that how the uh particular executions or
this Gradle project is being prepared in
case of eclipse selenium deletion is a
three-step process so it has certain
prereqs the first prerequis you need to
have Java on your system so we will be
installing Java first and then we will
be working with Eclipse ID so we will be
installing eclipse and then we will
install selenium for Java we will
install the version Java 8 and for
Eclipse we have a version 4.10 this was
the last table version which was
released in December last year so I'll
be using that version and selenium we
will download the latest 3.14 version
okay so let's get started with our first
step which is the Java installation so
to install Java let's go to the browser
and simply just search for Java 8
download
so now you will see that there is an
oracle site which is listed there and
that is where you would be downloading
all your Java package so go ahead and
click on that and for you to download
any jdk package from the Oracle site you
need to create an account so if you
already have one you just need to log in
using that account and then you can
download any of the jdkits and if you do
not have one please go ahead create a
new account on the Oracle log into that
account and then you can just download
the Java it so since I already have an
account and I have already downloaded
the package but I'll show you how and
where to download it from so in this
page if you scroll down so you will see
this Java development kit 8211 so this
is the version we'll be downloading it
so click on the accept license agreement
and then since we are working on the
Windows system today so we will be
downloading this the windows package so
just click on that and it will get
downloaded in your downloaded folder and
as I said I've already downloaded the
packages so here it is what I've done is
I've just created a directory called
installers and I'm going to be keeping
all my installables here so here I have
a folder called Java installer and this
is where my installable is so now that
we have this file so we will just go
ahead double click on it and launch this
installer the installer is launched and
just click on run so this will take a
few minutes to install Java the
installer is launched now just click on
the next button here so here for the
installation directory you can change
the directory to the choice of whatever
drive and the folder structure you want
to I would like to leave it as default
here and we'll just go and click on next
and then the Java installation is in
progress so let's wait until this is
completed it really shouldn't take too
much time maybe just a few more minutes
here
okay accept the license term just click
on next we'll leave the destination
folder as it is
so jdk8 is successfully installed on
your system so close the installer now
and let's go ahead and check whether the
installation is done properly so for
that what I'll do is I'll go to my
command prompt and I'll just say Java
minus version so it says Java version
1.8 and this tells us that the Java is
installed successfully now after this
installation there are couple of
configurations which we need to do and
what are those configurations one is you
need to set the path variable and then
we are also going to set a Java home
directory so for that first let's go
ahead and check where is the Java
installed actually let's figure out the
directory first so if you remember the
directory structure where the Java got
installed was in program files Java I
have there are certain previous versions
which are installed and then uninstalled
it so that is why you see some residuals
here sitting here that's not worry too
much about that instead let me go to the
latest one what I have installed which
is this okay and there is a bin folder
here and this is the path which we need
to set in our path variable so what I
will do is I'll just copy this path and
then go to your control panel here go to
your where is my system yeah so click on
the system go to Advanced system setting
and here in the environment variables
find the PATH variable okay and then say
edit now what are we doing here in the
path variable is we are going to add the
Java bin directory to the path be very
careful whenever you are editing your
path variable do not overwrite anything
always go into the edit mode go towards
the end here and then just say Ctrl V
paste the path which you have just
copied from the Explorer window that's
it now just say okay done so your path
setting is done so what's the next one
we need to do we need to add a new
environment variable called the Java now
what I'll do for that is I just say new
I just type Java home here and what is
the value of this we need to set we need
to set the same path but without the
print directory so we just need to set
the path till your Java directory that
is this so we'll just copy the path
again and paste it here that is all just
say Okay click on Okay click on OK here
and we are done so again let's go to our
Command Prompt and just say Java minus
version
so everything seems to be fine so now
successfully we have installed Java on
the system so what is our next
installation step what we have now we
need to install the eclipse so let's go
back to the browser again so to download
Eclipse we will be downloading the
package from the eclipse.org so when you
go here to eclipse.r you can see the
latest version which is available and
the latest version available when this
video was made was
20906. so especially with Eclipse since
it's an open source I prefer to work
with the last stable version and so does
most of the developers do and hence that
is the reason why I have picked up the
version which is like last year's
version which is 4.10 which was released
in last December so you can always
choose to go with the latest version but
then if there are any issues and if you
are like first time working with the
eclipse you're going to get confused as
where this issues are coming from right
so I would still recommend that you use
the last stable version which is
available with your Eclipse so now to
get the last stable version what you
need to do is go and click on this
download packages and here if if you
scroll down this page you can see here
more downloads so there is a list of all
the previous releases of app Clips which
is available and this is what we need to
download so just click on that 4.10
version and then click on the OS on
which you want to install eclipse for us
it is Windows so I'll just click here on
the 64-bit windows and then click on the
download and you will be downloading the
complete package so once you download
this is what it will look like so let's
go back to our directory of installers
so this is the installer for the Eclipse
which I got now what's the next step I
need to do just launch this installer
and install Eclipse so I'll just say
double click on this I'll say run
so here you will see multiple options
here for Eclipse installation so
depending on your requirement you can go
ahead and install any of these packages
so for us we just need an eclipse ID for
Java developers so I'll select this and
I'll say install so again you'll have a
choice of directory where you want to
install so I have chosen D drive here
this is a default directory name it is
which is okay we can leave it as it is
and then also you have an option to
create a start menu entry and desktop
shortcut so just leave the default
selection as it is and go ahead and
click on install so this will take a
while to install the eclipse
just say select all you can close this
window this is select all and accept it
okay so the installation has been
completed successfully so let's go and
click on this launch and let's see the
first window what opens
okay when you launch the eclipse you
need to specify a workspace directory
now what is this workspace directory so
this is a directory or a folder wherein
all the Java files or any programs or
any artifacts which you're going to
create through Eclipse will be stored in
this particular folder so this could be
any location on your system so this is
you can go ahead browse the location and
change it so for in our case what we
will do is I'll go to the D drive and I
already have a directory so here I'll
create I'll just create select this
folder and then create a folder called
workspace I'll say my workspace and then
I'll say launch so every time I open the
eclipse right so if this is going to
take as my default workspace and all my
programs all my javascripts or my
automation scripts are getting are going
to be stored in this particular location
so we'll say launch
so this is a welcome window which opens
we can just close this and there we go
the eclipse is open with a certain
perspective so there are certain Windows
here which we do not need let's just
close them so now the first thing what
you do after launching the eclipse is go
ahead and create a new project so I'll
say file new and since I'm going to be
using Java with selenium I'll say create
Java project so give a project name
let's say my first project now you have
an option here to select the JRE which
you want to use so we just install this
jdk 1.8 okay so I'm going to click on
use default GRE otherwise you also have
an option to use a Project Specific gr
for example I could have two different
projects where one project I'm going to
be working with GRE 1.8 and there is
another project which I want to work
with the latest Java maybe Java 12 and I
can have more than one Java installed on
the machine so this gives me an option
to select whichever Java I want to work
with so if you have another Java
installed here it will show up in this
list so and you can just go ahead and
select that now since we have only one
Java installed on our machine which is
Java 1.8 I will say use default GRE
which is 1.8 and I will click on finish
now if You observe this folder structure
the project which is created see all the
reference libraries to this particular
Java have been created here now we are
ready to create any kind of java
programs in this project so now we have
successfully done the second step of our
installation which is the eclipse
installation after this we need to
install the selenium so again let's go
back to the browser and see what files
we need to download to install Selena so
let me go to my browser and here I will
be going to the
seleniumhq.org so if you are working
with selenium this particular website
the seleniumhq.org is going to be a
Bible everything and anything related to
selenium is available in this website
whether you want to download the files
whether you want to refer to the
documentation anything regarding to
selenium is available here so what we
want now is the installables for
selenium so here go to the the download
tab now for you to install selenium and
start working with selenium there are
three things which are required for you
to download one is a standalone selenium
server so this is not required
immediately when you get started with
selenium however when you start working
with remote selenium Webdriver you would
be requiring this when you have a grid
setup you will be requiring the
Standalone server so for that what you
can do is you can just download the
latest version available here so when
you click on that it'll download the
file into your download folder so this
is one particular file which you need to
keep next selenium client and Webdriver
language bindings now in today's demo we
will be looking at selenium with Java so
that means my client package of java is
what I need to download so whatever
programming language selenium supports
we have respective downloadables
available with that so if you're working
with python then you need to download
your client library for Python and since
we are working with Java you need to
download this package so simply what you
need to do click on this link and it
will download the Java package file
which are basically the jar
so we have client libraries now and then
there is another component what we need
now with a linear you're going to be
automating your web browser applications
correct and you also want your
applications to run on multiple browsers
so that means your scripts the
automation scripts which you create
should be able to run on any browser
selenium works with multiple browsers
like Edge Safari Chrome Firefox and
other browsers even it has a support for
headless browser now every browser which
it supports comes with its own driver
file now say for example we want to say
work with Firefox driver so that means
for us to start working with Firefox
browser we need to download something
called as a gecko driver here and if you
want to work with Chrome browser you
need to install the Chrome driver so
depending on what browsers you'll be
testing with go ahead Click on each of
this link and download the latest driver
files now since we are going to be
working with Firefox in this demo what I
need to do is I just need to click here
on the latest click so when I click on
the latest link it is going to take me
to this driver files so driver files are
specific to each of the operating system
so if you go down here you will see
there is a separate driver file
available for Linux for mac and for
Windows so depending on which operating
system where you'll be running your test
download that particular driver file and
this is the driver file I need because
we are working on Windows machine so
these are the three different packages
which we need to download from the
selenium hq.org for us to install
selling so let me show you the folder
where I have already downloaded all this
so if you see here selenium Java
3.141.59 okay this is nothing but our
client Library which we saw here let's
go back to the main page here that is
this so once I download this this is a
ZIP file after I unzip the file this is
the folder structure I see and let's see
what is there in this folder so there
are two jar files here and then in the
lips there are multiple jar files and we
will need all this to work with selling
it and then we also downloaded the
driver files so what I did was after
downloading those driver files for the
browser I created a directory here
called drivers and I've kept all my
browser drivers here so I have a driver
file downloaded for Chrome I want to
work with Firefox so I have a gecko
driver here and then for Internet
Explorer that's it so this is all we
need so once we have all this what you
need to do is go to your eclipse in the
eclipse right click on the project which
you have created and then go to the
build path and say configure build path
go to the libraries tab here now do you
see this JRE libraries here this is what
got installed first and now similarly we
are going to add the selenium jars to
this library and how do we add that on
your right you can see this add external
jars click on ADD external Jazz go to
your folder where you have downloaded
your selenium which is this select all
the jar files which is available so I
have two jar files here I'll just say
click open again I will click on ADD
external jar now from the lips folder I
will select all the this fight so just
select all the five jars and click on
open so you should see all the seven jar
files here so once you have this just
say apply and close now if you look into
your project directory here you'll see
some a folder called referenced library
and this is where you will see all the
selenium charts here this is a very
simple installation in Eclipse when you
want to install selenium you just need
to export all the jars of the selenium
into eclipse and now your system is
ready to start working with selenium
scripts all right so now let's just test
our installation by writing a small
selenium test script so for that what I
will do is I'll go to the source folder
right click new and I'll say Java class
so let's name this as say first selenium
test and I will select this public
static white Main and I will click on
finish all right so now let's create a
use case say we want to launch a Firefox
browser and then we want to launch the
Amazon site so these will be just two
simple things which we will be doing in
this test script so for me to do that
what I usually do is I create a method
for any functionality which I want to
create here so now I want to do a launch
browser so I'll create a method here
called launch browser now whenever you
start writing your selenium scripts the
first line what you need to do is you
need to declare an object of Webdriver
class so here I'll say
Webdriver driver driver so now if you
hover over this error what it is showing
it says import web driver from or dot
open QA dot selling it so if you
remember when we installed the selenium
we imported all these jars right so that
means what whenever we want to use a web
driver we need to import this class from
these packages so just go ahead and
click on this import State done now next
step now for us to launch a Firefox
browser it is a two steps process which
is involved here one is you need to set
the system property and then you need to
launch the driver so let's do that I'll
say system dot set property so use this
method set property so this takes two
arguments the key and the value pair now
what is the key I'm going to mention
here I am going to be mentioning the
gecko driver and the path for the gecko
driver okay because since I'm working
with the Firefox so in double quotes
I'll say
webdriver.geco.driver this is my key and
the value is going to be sorry the fully
qualified path for your driver files and
you know know where we have kept our
driver files let's go to that driver
files in D colon I have selenium
tutorial in installers I have driver
folder okay so I'm just going to copy
the complete path from here Ctrl C and I
paste it here Ctrl V along with this I
need to provide the file name for the
gecko driver which is gecko driver dot
exe and let's complete this step next so
once I've set the property I need to
provide a command for launching my
Firefox driver and how do I do that I
simply use this driver object which I
have created driver equal to
new Firefox driver again similarly the
way we imported packages for web driver
we also need to import the package for
Firefox driver so just hover over the
mouse over that and select import
Firefox tracker with these two
statements we will be able to launch the
Firefox browser and as I said in our use
case what is the next thing we want to
do we want to launch say amazon.in
website for that there is a command in
selenium which says driver dot get and
you pass the URL here so for me to write
the URL what I usually do is I go to my
browser I open the website which I want
to work with in our case it's amazon.in
and I just simply copy this fully formed
URL go to my clips and just paste it
here now this ensures that I don't make
any mistakes in typing out the URL let's
complete the statement and we are done
and now in the main function I'll just
create an object of this and we will
call this method so I'll copy this class
for selenium test say obj equal to new
for selenium test and now I'll say obj
dot this is a function launch process so
let's save this and execute this Ctrl C
right click run as Java application okay
so the Mozilla Firefox has been launched
now it should launch your amazon.bingo
so there goes our first test script
which runs successfully if getting your
learning started is half the battle what
if you could do that for free visit
scale up by simply learn click on the
link in the description to know more
for you before you start understanding
any automation tool it's good to look
back into what manual testing is all
about what are its challenges and how
automation tool overcomes these
challenges challenges are always
overcome by inventing something new so
let's see how selenium came into
existence and how did it evolve to
become one of the most popular web
application automation tool selenium
Suite of tools selenium is not a single
tool it has multiple components so we
will look into each of them and as you
know every automation tool has its own
advantages and limitations so we will be
looking at what the advantages are and
the limitations of selenium and how do
we work around those limitations all
right so let's get started manual
testing a definition if you can say a
manual testing involves the physical
execution of test cases against various
applications and to do what to detect
bugs and errors in your product it is
one of the Primitive methods of testing
a software this was the only method
which we knew of earlier it is execution
of test cases without using any
automation tools it does not require the
knowledge of a testing tool obviously
because everything is done manually also
you can practically test any application
since you are doing a manual testing so
let's take an example so say we have a
use case you are testing say a Facebook
application and in Facebook application
let's let's open the Facebook
application and say create an account
this is your web page which is under
test now now as a tester what would you
do you would write multiple test cases
to test each of the functionalities on
this page you will use multiple data
sets to test each of these fields like
the first name the surname mobile number
or the new password and you will also
test multiple links what are the
different links on this page like say
forgotten account or create a new page
so these are the multiple links
available on the web pages also you look
at each and every element of the web
page like your radio buttons like your
drop down list apart from this you would
do an access ability testing you would
do a performance testing for this pitch
or say a response time after you say
click on the login button literally you
can do any type of tests manually once
you have these test cases ready what do
you do you start executing this test
cases one by one you will find bugs your
developers are going to fix them and you
will need to rerun all these test cases
one by one again until all the bugs are
fixed and your application is ready to
ship now if one has to run test cases
with hundreds of transactions or the
data sets and repeat them can you
imagine the amount of effort required in
that now that brings us to the first
demerit of the manual testing manual
testing is a very time consuming process
and it is very boring also it is very
highly error prone why because it is
done annually and human mistakes are
bound to happen since it's a manual
executions tester's presence is required
all the time one is to keep doing manual
Steps step by step again all the time he
also has to create manual reports group
them format them so that we get good
looking reports also send this reports
manually to all stakeholders then
collection of logs from various machines
where you have run your test consoliding
all of them creating repositories and
maintaining them and again since it's
all as a manual process there is a high
chance of creating manual errors there
scope of manual testing is limited for
example let's say regression testing
ideally you would want to run all the
test cases which you have written but
since it's a manual process you would
not have the luxury of time to execute
all of them and hence you will pick and
choose your test cases to execute that
way you are limiting the scope of
testing also working with large amount
of data manually is Impractical which
could be the need of your application
what about performance testing you want
to collect metrics on various
performance measures as a part of your
performance testing you want to simulate
multiple loads on application under test
and hence manually performing these kind
of test is not feasible and to top it
all up say if you're working in an agile
model where code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
test and they are executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run this test multiple
times during your development cycle and
doing this manually definitely becomes
very tedious and burning and is this the
effective way of doing it not at all so
what do we do we automate it so this
tells us why we automate one for faster
execution two to be less error prone and
three the main reason is to help
frequent execution of our test so there
are many tools available in the market
today for automation one such tool is
selenium birth of selenium much before
selenium there were various tools in the
market like say rft and qtp just to name
a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentlemen called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a JavaScript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test run later he made this
open source and this was renamed as the
selenium core and this is how selenium
came into existence and since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in Speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate No human errors since your
test cases are automated Human Resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
Market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like Internet Explorer Chrome Firefox
Safari Edge Opera and even the Headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge so selenium has
this record and replay back tool called
the selenium ID which can be used to
create a set of actions as a script and
you can replay the script back however
this is mainly used for demo purposes
only because selenium is such a powerful
tool that you should be able to take
full advantage of all its features
selenium provides support for different
programming languages like Java python
c-sharp Ruby so you can write your test
scripts in any language you like one
need not know in-depth or Advanced
knowledge of these languages also
selenium supports different operating
systems it has purpose for Windows Macs
Linux even Ubuntu as well so so you can
run your selenium test on any platform
of your choice and hence selenium is the
most popular and widely used automation
tools for automating your web
applications selenium set of tools so
let's go a little more deeper into
selenium as I said selenium is not a
single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium ID
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium IDE was
available only as a Firefox plugin and
it offered a simple recorded playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
Automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay tool
selenium RC this is nothing but selenium
remote control it is used to write web
application test in different
programming language what it does it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is it uses a
simple HTTP post get request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by Webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium Suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute test cases it is obviously the
successor of the selenium RC which we
talked about because of certain
drawbacks which RC hat so what Webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike RC where the RC required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium web driver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and why is
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test Automation and we will
go in detail about each of this
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an IDE RC and grit and as I said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
RC so RC was on its path of deprecation
and web driver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of Webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from three dot
onwards RC was completely mode and
Webdriver took its place there is also a
four dot version around the corner and
it has more features and enhancements
some some of the features which are
talked about are w3c Webdriver
standardization improved ID and improved
grid now let's look at each of the
components in the selenium Suite
selenium IDE is the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is nothing
but an integrated development
environment for creating your automation
scripts it has a record and Playback
functionality and is a very simple and
easy to use tool it is available as a
Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension so
you can use either of this browser to
record your test scripts it's a very
simple user interface using which you
can create your scripts that interact
with your browser the commands created
in the scripts are called selenis
commands and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other recorded
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium ID was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
version one selenium ID died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID was
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium ID has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on Chrome as well as as an
add-on on Firefox browser so they
completely revamped this IDE code and
now they have made it available on the
GitHub under the Apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new ID now with this new ID also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports pattern test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side Runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using IDC
on Chrome or Firefox but through command
prompt using your site Runner you can
execute this test cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while Loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the Firefox browser so on
this browser I already have the ID
installed so when you already have an ID
installed you will see an icon here
which says selenium ID and how do you
install this you simply need to go to
your Firefox add-ons here whether it
says find more extension so just type in
selenium ID and search for the sixth
section so in the search results you see
the selenium ID just click on that and
now since I've already installed here it
says remove otherwise for you it is
going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ID icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this ID so when I
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is it says
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so I already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so I'll go ahead and open that
so I'll say open existing project and I
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
Facebook using a dummy user mail sorry
username and password that's all it's a
very simple script with few lines and
this is what it's going to do so what we
will simply do is we'll just run the
script and see how it works for that I'm
just going to reduce the test execution
speed so that you should be able to see
every step of execution here all right
so what I'll do now here is I'll just
adjust this window and I'll just simply
say run current test all right so I'll
just get this side by side so that you
should be able to see what exactly the
script is doing okay so now you are able
to see both the windows okay so now it's
going to type in your user email here
there you go and now it will enter the
password and it is clicked on the login
button so it's going to take a while to
say login and since these are the dummy
IDs it is you are not able to log in
here and you're going to see this error
window fine that is what is the expected
output here now on the ID if you look
here after I execute the test case every
statement or every command which I have
used here is color coded in green so
that means this particular step was
executed successfully and then here in
the log window it will give you a
complete lock of this test case right
from the first step till the end and
your end result is it says FB login
which is my test case name completed
successful let's look at few components
of this ID the first one is the menu bar
so let's go to our ID all right so the
menu bar is right here on the top so
here is your project name so either you
can add a new project here or rename
your project so since we already have
this project which is named as Facebook
and then on the right you have options
to create a new project open an existing
project or save the current project and
then comes on toolbar so using the
options in this toolbar you can control
the execution of your test cases so
first one here is the recording button
so this is what you use when you start
recording your script and then on the
left you have two options here to run
your test cases the first one is run all
tests so in case you have multiple test
cases written here you can execute them
one by one sequentially by using this
run all test else what you can do so if
you just want to run your current test
this is what you would use then idea has
this debugger option which you can use
to do a step execution so say for
example now whenever I run the script
it's going to execute each and every
command here sequentially so instead if
I just select the first command and say
do step execution all right so what it
does is the moment it finishes the First
Command which is opening of Facebook
right I think which is already done here
yeah all right so once this is done it
is going to wait immediately on the
second command and it says pause the
debugger so from here you can do
whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if we
say run the test case what it is going
to do is it's just going to Simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there
which says test execution speed so to
execute your test cases in the speed you
want say whenever you're developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
Fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which I showed was I
control the speed and then I executed it
so that we could see every command how
it is being executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whichever Wherever Whenever you
enter an URL here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it gives a history of
all the URLs which I've used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded So each and every
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or filled so in case there is a failure
you will immediately see this test case
is filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if I click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to to show me is details of this
command which I have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this ID so
with this you'll get an ideas how do we
actually record scripts in ID so for
that I have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon.in then we'll search
simply search for say a product iPhone
and once we get that search page where
all your iPhones are displayed we will
just do an assert on the title of the
page simple all right so let's do that
so first thing what I need is an URL
okay so first let me go to my Firefox
browser here and say amazon.in so why
I'm doing this just to Simply get the
right URL absolute URL path here and so
that I don't make any mistakes while
typing in the URL okay so I got this so
let me close all this windows I don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what I will do in the
tests tab I'll say add a new test and
name this test as uh Amazon search done
I'll say add now I'll enter this URL
which I just copied it from my browser
okay and then I'll just say start
recording so what it did was since I've
entered the URL in this address box it
just opened the amazon.in URL now let's
do the test case so in my test case what
I said was I want to search for iPhone
once I have this I'm just going to click
on my search button so now this gives me
a list of all iPhones and then I said I
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is I have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium ID options here
so in this I will select assert title
and then I will close this browser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
is created for me so it says open slash
because I've already provided the URL
here so either you can replace it with
your regular URL or you can just leave
it as it is so what I will do since this
is going to be a proper script and I
might be using this to run it from my
command prompt also so I'll just replace
this target with the actual URL and then
what it is doing it is setting a window
size then there are whatever I did on
that particular URL on that website it
has recorded all the steps for me so
this is where it says type into this
particular text box which is my search
box and what did it type iPhone this was
the value which I entered now there was
one more feature which I told you in
this new ID which had which I said it
has a failover mechanism for your
locating techniques now that is what
this is now if you look here this ID is
equal to two tab search text box this is
nothing but the search box where we
entered the text iPhone and it has
certain identification through which
this IDE identifies that web element and
that has multiple options means to
select that particular search box so
right now what it has used is ID is
equal to two tab search box however if
you know the different locating
techniques you will be able to see here
that it has other techniques also which
it has identified like the name and the
CSS and the XPath so how does this help
in failovers say tomorrow if Amazon dot
in website changes the ID of this
element right you are not going to come
and rewrite the scripts again instead by
using the same script what it will do is
if this particular ID fails if it is
unable to find the element using the
first locator which is the ID it simply
moves to the next available ones and it
tries to search for that element until
one of this becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
assert Title Here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then I've also
given a closed browser so right now what
I will do is I'll just comment this out
why because if I just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now I'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now I'll just say run the
current test so your Amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iPhone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the lock so it's going to be
running lock so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
Facebook is also in the same lock so we
all have to see the log from running
Amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right it was executed success fully
assert title was also done and your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title I'll just modify this and
let's say just add some text I'll just
add double s here now this by
intentionally I am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the ID behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so I'll just
run the test test case again so before
that let's close the previous window all
right done and now here I'll also
uncomment the close because anyway it's
a failure which I'm going to see which I
should be able to see it in the logs so
I'll close the browser after the
execution of test case Okay so let's
simply go and run the test case Okay
amazon.in is launched it should search
for iPhone now yeah there you go all
right now it should also close the
browser yes let us close the browser and
it has failed now see here now this is
the line where our Command fit why
because the expected title was not there
and if you look in the logs it says your
assert title on Amazon dot in failed and
actual result was something different
and it did not match with what we had
asked it for so this is how simple it is
to use your ID to create your automation
scripts so we saw all the components of
ID we saw the record button then I
showed you the toolbar I showed you the
editor box and also the test execution
lock so now let's come to what are the
limitations of this ID with IDE you
cannot export your scripts your test
scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
The Works Data driven testing like using
your Excel files or reading data from
the CSV files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database for reading your test data or
perform any kind of database testing
with selenium Webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium Webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
ID like say for example test NG or
report NC so that brings us to the next
component of The Suite which is selenium
r see selenium remote control so
selenium RC was developed by Paul
Hammond he refactored the code which was
developed by Jason and was credited with
Jason as a co-creator of selenium
selenium server is written in Java it is
used to write web application tests in
different programming languages as it
supports multiple programming languages
like your Java C sharp Pearl Python and
Ruby it interacts with the browser with
the help of an RC server so this RFC
server uses a simple HTTP get and post
request for communication and as I said
earlier also selenium RC was called as
selenium 1.0 overshill but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3.0 and it got
replaced by what web driver and we'll
see why this happened and what was that
issue which we had with the RC server so
this is the architecture of selenium
remote control at a very high level so
when Jason Huggins introduced selenium
you know the tool was called as
JavaScript program and then that was
also is a selenium core so every HTML
has a JavaScript statements which are
executed by web browser and there is a
JavaScript engine which helps in
executing this command now this RC had
one major issue now what was that issue
say for example you have a test script
say test dot JavaScript here which you
are trying to access a limits from
anywhere from the google.com domain so
what used to happen is every element
which is accessible are the elements
which can belong only to google.com
domain like say for example mail the
search or the drive so any elements from
this can be accessible through your test
scripts however nothing outside the
domain of say google.com in this case
was accessible say for example if your
test scripts wanted to access something
from yahoo.com this was not possible and
this is due to the security reasons
obviously now to overcome that the
testers what they had to do was they had
to install the selenium core and the web
server which contained your web
application which is under test on the
same machine and imagine if you have to
do this for every machine which is under
test this is not going to be feasible or
even effective all the time and this
issue is called as the same origin
policy now what the same origin policy
issue says is it prohibits a JavaScript
from accessing elements or interacting
with scripts from my domain different
from where it is launched and this is
purely for the security measure so if
you have written a scripts which can
access your google.com or anything
related to google.com these scripts
cannot access any elements outside the
domain like as we said in the example
yahoo.com this was the same origin
policy now to overcome this what this
gentleman did was he created something
called as selenium remote control server
to trick the browser in believing that
your course your selenium core and your
web application under test are from the
same domain and this is what was the
selenium remote control so if you look
at again a high level architecture or
how did this actually work first you
write your test scripts which is here
right in any of the supported language
like your PHP or your Java or Python and
before we start testing we need to
launch this RC server which is a
separate application so this selenium
server is responsible for receiving the
Cellini's commands and these Cellini's
commands are the ones which you have
written in your script it interprets
them and reports the result back to your
test so all that is done to your RC
server the browser interaction which
happens through RC server right from
here to your browser so this happens
through a simple HTTP post and get
request and that is how your RC server
and your browser communicate and how
exactly this communication happens this
RC server it acts like a proxy so say
your test scripts asked to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your RC
server launches the browser it injects
the JavaScript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your your test script right from
your test scripts to your browser goes
through your RC and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium code executes this actual
commands as JavaScript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
RC to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
JavaScript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the RC server to the browser
collecting the results again from the RC
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so RC had definitely a lot of
shortcomings and what are those so RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your selling is
commands and your browser the
architecture of RC is applicated why
because of its intermediate RC server
which is required to communicate with
the browser the execution of commands
takes very long it is slower we know why
because every command in this takes a
full trip from the test script to your
RC server to the core engine to the
browser and then back to the same route
which makes your overall test execution
very slow lastly the API is supported by
RC are very redundant and confusing so
RC does have a good number of apis
however it is less object oriented so
they are redundant and confusing say for
example say if you want to write into a
text box how and when to use a type key
command or just a type command is always
confusing another example is some of the
mouse commas using a click or a mouse
door both kind of you know almost
providing a similar functionality so
that is the kind of confusion which
developers use to create hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in later selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. It's a class platform
testing platform so Webdriver can run on
any platform like say Linux Windows Mac
or even if you have a Ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ID and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver method so
when I do a demo you will understand
what this Webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like RC so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the RC hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you will be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say Chrome and then the
Chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC Webdriver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test Scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various Frameworks like test NG
junit and unit and report and check so
when we talk about the limitations of
Webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various Frameworks and tools
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
Webdriver at a high level what is in
Webdriver so Webdriver consists of four
major components the first one is we
have got client libraries right or what
we also call it as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if I go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your Bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all the
stabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that I'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you're
working with Java here what you need to
do is you need to download your Java
language binding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser and when we do
the demo I'll be showing you some of
this APS right and these are nothing but
the rest apis and everything whatever we
do through the script happens through
the rest calls then we have a Json wire
protocol what is Json JavaScript object
notation it is nothing but a standard
for exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
Json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as I said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation so does selenium so let's
look at what these limitations are and
if there are any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like APM
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool which is
nothing but a mobile application
automation tool and using APM and
selenium you can still achieve mobile
application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium I said that with Webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of web driver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video on simply
learn website on selenium grid third
limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium Webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test engine report NG and even extend
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it also there are other
challenges with selenium like selenium
is not very good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like autoit
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the web driver
so RC has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser web driver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is slower in RC and much faster in
Webdriver why because in Webdriver we
have eliminated that complete layer of
selenium server right that the RC server
and we established a direct
communication with the browser through
browser drivers it requires an RCA
server to interact with the browsers we
just talked about it and whereas
Webdriver can directly interact with the
browser
so RC again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant ABS which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however Webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
ASI did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in Webdriver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium 3.0 training
so we are basically searching for
selenium 3.0 training on the simply
learn website first let's do the steps
manually and then we will go ahead and
write the automation script so let's go
to my browser on my browser what I'll do
is let me first launch the simply learn
website
okay and here what my use case step says
is I need to search for selenium and
click on the search button so once I do
that it is going to give me a complete
list of all kind of selenium trainings
which is available with simpler and what
I'm interested in is the selenium 3.0
training here once I find this on the
web page I need to go and click on that
all right so this is all the steps which
we are going to perform in this use case
okay now so for writing the test cases
I'll be using an ID which is Eclipse
I've already installed my eclipse and
also I have installed selenium in this
instance of my Eclipse all right so if
you can see the reference library folder
here you will see all the jars which are
required for the selenium to work next
another prereq which is required for
selenium and that is your driver files
now every browser which you want to work
with has its own driver file to execute
your selenium scripts and since for this
demo I'll be working with the Firefox
browser I will need a driver file for
Firefox now driver file for Firefox is
the gecko driver which I have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did I download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if I go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium HQ dot website you have
to go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
I am working on Mac this is the file
which I'm using if you are a Windows
user you need to download this ZIP file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
Firefox or a chrome driver for your
Chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class I already have a
package created in this project so I'll
use this project and create a new class
so I'll say create new Java class and
let's call this as search training I'll
be using a public static wordman and
I'll click on finish so let's remove
this Auto generated lines as we do not
need them all right now the first
statement which you need to write before
even you start writing the rest of your
code is what you need to do is you need
to define or declare your driver
variable using your class web driver so
what I would do is I'll say Webdriver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this ID is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import web driver
from org dot opensq.cellaneous this is
the package which we will need all right
so you have a driver created which is of
the class web driver and now after this
I'm going to create three methods all
right so first method I will have for
launching the Firefox browser okay and
then I will write a simple method for
searching
selenium training and clicking on it
this is the actual use case what we'll
be doing and then third method I'm going
to write is just to close the browser
which I'm going to be opening right so
these are the different methods which
I'll be creating and from the public
static wordman I will just call these
methods one after the other okay so
let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the Firefox browser so I'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser okay all right
now in this for launching any browser I
need to mention two steps now the first
step is where I need to do a system.set
property okay let's do that first and
then I'll explain what this does I'll
just say system dot set property so this
accepts a key and a value pair so what
is my key here my key here is Webdriver
dot gecko dot driver and I need to
provide a value so value is nothing but
the path to the gecko driver and we know
that this gecko driver which I'm going
to use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
I'm going to provide here so here simply
I need to say drivers slash gecko driver
gecko all right done and let me close
this sentence all right now since I am a
Mac User my gecko driver installable is
just the name gecko driver if your
windows user and if you are running your
selenium scripts on the Windows machine
you need to provide a complete path to
this including dot exe because driver
executable on your machines is going to
be gecko driver.exe all right so just
make sure that your path which you
mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is I
need to just say driver is equal to new
Firefox driver okay so this command new
Firefox driver creates an instance of
the Firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the Firefox driver class is
present okay we did that now these two
lines are responsible for launching the
Firefox browser form so this is done so
what's my next step in the use case now
I need to launch the website simply
learn so for that we have a command
called driver dot get driver dot get
what it does is whatever URL you're
going to give it here in this double
quotes as an argument it is going to
launch that particular website and for
us it's a simply learn website so what I
do as a best practices instead of typing
out the URL I go to my browser launch
that URL which I want to test and I
simply copy it come back to your eclipse
and just simply paste it so this ensures
that I do not make any mistakes in the
URL okay so done so our first method is
ready where we are launching the browser
which is our Firefox browser and then
launching the simply learn website now
the next method what is my next method
in my next method I need to give the
search string to search selenium
training on this particular website now
for that we need to do few things what
are those few things let's go to the
website again all right so let me
relaunch this let's close this okay let
me remove all this and let's go to the
home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the text here
so now since I have to write a script
for this first I need to identify what
this element is for that what I am going
to do is I'm just going to say right
click here and I'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which I can use
for finding this element so I I see that
there is an ID present so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to Simply use
this ID and then I'll just copy this ID
from here go back to Eclipse let's write
a method first so I'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training or just search all right
now in this I need to use a command
called driver dot find element by ID is
what I'm going to use as a locating
technique and in double quotes the ID
which I copied from the website is what
I'm going to paste here okay and then
what am I going to do on this element is
I need to send that text the text which
I'm going to search for which is
selenium so I'll just say send keys and
whatever text I want to send I need to
give it in double quotes So for that
selenium so this is done so now I've
entered the text here and after entering
the text I need to click on this button
so for that I need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name I do
not have anything here all right so what
I can do is I can either use the class
name or I can write an X path since this
is a demo which we have already used ID
locating technique I would go ahead and
use the X path here so for me to
construct an X path I will copy this
class first okay and then I already have
a crow path installed on my Firefox so
I'll use the crop path and first test my
X bar so I'll just say double slash
let's see what was that element it has a
span tag okay so I'll have to use span
and at class equal to and I'll just copy
the class name here and let's see if it
can identify that element yeah so it is
able to identify so I'll just use this x
path in my code so I'll go back to
Eclipse I'll say driver dot find element
by dot X path and the X path which I
just copied from cropath is what I'm
going to paste here and what is the
action I need to do here I need to say
click done so I have reached a stage
where I have entered this selenium okay
and then I have clicked on the search
button once I do this I know that
expected result is I should be able to
find this particular link here selenium
3.0 training okay and I should be able
to click on that so for that again I
need to inspect this so let's inspect
this selenium 3.2 all right so now what
are the elements this has now this
particular element has attributes like
it has a tag H2 then it has got some
class name and some other attributes so
I would again would like to use a x path
here now this time while using the X
path I am going to make use of a text
functionality so that I can search for
this particular text so I'll simply copy
this I'll go to my Crow path the tag is
H2 so I'll say simply H2 okay and here
I'll say text equal to and this is the
text which I copied I missed out that
yes there so I'm just going to add an S
okay so let's first test here whether it
is able to identify that element yeah so
it is able to identify so can you see
your blue dotted line it is able to show
us which element it is identified so
I'll copy this x path now and let's go
to my ID Eclipse so now here what I need
to do is I'll have to again simply say
driver dot find element by dot X path
and paste the X path which we just did
and then again I have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that now let's add an additional
thing here say after coming to this page
after finding this we want to uh say
print the title of this page now what is
the title of this page if you just hover
your mouse on this it says online and
classroom training for professional
certification courses simply now so what
I will do is after doing all these
operations I will just print out this
page title on our console so for that I
have to just do this drive dot so let's
do a sys out so I'll say sys out
system.out.println okay and here I would
say let's add a text here the page title
is and then let's append it with driver
dot get title so this is the command
which we'll be using to fetch the page
title done now what is the last method I
need to add just to close the browser
all right so let me add a method here
I'll say public void close browser and
it's a one single command which I need
to call I'll say driver dot quit Okay
and then I need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search right and
then I'll call the method close process
done so technically our script is is
ready with all the functionality which
we wanted to cover from our use case now
there are few other tweaks which I need
to do this and I'll tell you why I need
to do this now for example after we
click here right after we click on the
search if you observed on your website
it took a little while before it listed
out all the selenium trainings for us
and usually when you are actually doing
it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of favorites now since
this is a demo for demo purpose what I'm
going to do is I am going to use a
command curve thread.sleep and I'm just
going to give an explicit weight of say
three seconds so you can use this many
only for the demo purposes you can use a
thread.sleep command now this
thread.sleep commands needs us to handle
some exceptions so I'm just going to
click on ADD throws declaration and say
interrupted exception now same thing
I'll have to do it in my main function
also okay so let's do that and complete
it all right so this is done so by doing
this what am I doing I'm ensuring that
before I click on the selenium three dot
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the web page
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing I'm doing all
right and also now since you are going
to be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly I'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what I'll do is I'll just give a
simple thread.sleep here
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds which should be good enough okay
three seconds weight should be good
enough here so that we should be able to
see how exactly this works on your
browser when we execute this okay now
our complete script is ready so what
I'll do is I'll just save the script and
then we will simply run the script so to
run the script I just say right click
run as Java application okay it says ask
me to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simply learn.com the website is
launched so the selenium text has been
entered in the search box it has clicked
on the search okay all right so now it
did everything whatever we wanted it to
do all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what I have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what we'll
do since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3. training or
not I'll just comment out the closed
browser the command okay so we will not
call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this Firefox window
close all tabs and then I'll just
re-execute the script so I'll say run as
Java application so save the file okay
simplylearn.com is launched so search
text is entered now it's going to click
on the search button yes all right so
we've got the search results it should
click on selenium 3.0 training and yes
it is successfully able to click on that
all right so now it's not going to close
the browser because we have commented on
that line however it did print us the
title here all right so this is a simple
way of using the selenium Scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with Webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grade comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by Patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallelly so design
is in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run tests and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has as a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
systems like as in this picture you
could say one of them is a Windows
machine one of them is a Mac machine and
another one say a Linux machine so your
requirement is to run the test on all
supported browsers and operating system
like the one which is depicted in this
picture so what you have to do is first
thing is you configure a Master machine
or what you also call it as a hub by
running something called a selenium
Standalone server and this Talent
Standalone server can be downloaded from
the selenium HQ website using the server
you create a hub configuration that is
this node and then you create nodes
specific to your machine requirement and
how are these nodes created you again
use the same server which is your
Standalone selenium server to create the
node configuration so I'll show you
where the selenium server can be
downloaded so if we go back to our
selenium HQ website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
Standalone server welcome everyone to
our one another demo on which we are
going to see that how exactly we can do
the installation of Docker on the
Windows platform specifically on Windows
10. now Docker is something which is
available for most of the operating
systems different different platforms so
it supports both the Unix and the
windows platform as such so Linux
through various commands we can do the
installation but in the case of Windows
you have to download the exe file and a
particular installer from the docker Hub
websites you can simply Google it and
you will get a kind of a link from where
you will be able to download the package
so let's go to the Chrome and try to
search on for the windows string uh
particular installer you will get a link
from Docker Hub you download it you get
the stable version you get the edge
version whichever version you want you
wish to download you can download it so
let's go back to the Chrome so here you
have the docker next store for Windows
so you can go for this table or you can
go for the edge right so you also have
the comparison that what is the
difference between these two versions
right so um the particular Edge version
is something which is getting releases
every month and uh the stable version is
getting the releases every quarter so
they are not doing much of the changes
to the stable version as compared to the
edge there so you just have to double
click on the installer and that will
help you to do the installation of the
process so let's get started so you just
click on the get in stable version so
when you do that the particular
installer is going to install now it's
going to take like around 300 MB there
so that's the kind of installed which is
available so once the installer is
downloaded so what you can do is that
you can actually go ahead and you can
proceed with the doing the double click
on this installer when you double click
on that you have to proceed with some of
the steps like you know from the GUI
itself you are going to proceed with
these steps so we'll wait for 10 to 20
seconds more and then the installer will
be done and then we can do the double
click and the installation will proceed
so another thing is that uh there is a
huge difference between the installer
like for example in case of Unix they
installed is a little bit less but in
case of windows it's a GUI is also
involved and there are a lot of binders
which is available there so that's the
reason why you know the Hue size is
there now it's available for free that's
for sure and it also requires the
Windows 10 professional or Enterprise
64-bit there so um if you are working on
some previous uh version of operating
systems like Windows 7 and all you have
the older version called Docker toolbox
so they used to call it as like Docker
toolbox earlier but now they are calling
it as in Docker desktop with a new
Docker Windows 10 support as such here
so another couple of seconds and then
the installer will be done and then we
will be able to proceed with the
installation
so let's see that how much progress is
there to the download so we'll click on
the downloads and here still we have
some particular installations or some
download going on so we'll wait for some
time and once the installation is done
then we'll go back and we'll proceed
with installation
so couple of seconds
so it's almost done so I'll just click
on this one you can go to the directory
to the downloads and you can double
click on that also but if you want to do
the installation you can click on this
one also and it will ask for the
approval yes or no you have to provide
now once that is done so um a desktop a
kind of a GUI component will open there
so it will start proceeding with the
installation so it's asking whether you
want to add a desktop the shortcut to
desktop so you can say okay I'm going to
click on OK so it will unpack the files
all the files which is required for
Docker to successfully install that is
getting unpacked over here so it will
take some time to do the installation
because it's doing a lot of work here so
you can just wait for till the execution
of the installer to be completed and
once the installer is done you can open
your command line and start working on
the docker
so taking some time to extract the files
now it's asking us to you know do the
close and do the restart so once that is
done you will be able to proceed further
and you can just you know run the
command line and any Docker command if
you can run so that will give you the
response whether the docker is installed
or not so you can see here that Docker
is you know something which is installed
so you can run like Docker version you
will be able to get a version of the
client when you do the restart of the
machine then add that moment of time the
docker server will also be started and
then this particular error message will
go off right now the docker demon is not
up and running because the installation
requires a restart and when you close on
this one and go for the restart the
machine will be restarted here so this
is the way that how exactly we can go
for a Docker installation and we can go
on that part so now let's begin with the
demo we'll be installing Docker on an
Ubuntu system so this is my system I
just open the terminal so the first
thing you can start with is removing any
Docker installation that you probably
already have present in your system if
you want to start from scratch so this
is the command to do so sudo app get
removed docker
dock engine Docker dot IO enter your
password
and Docker is removed so now we'll start
from scratch and we'll install Docker
once again before that I'll just clear
my screen
okay so before I install Docker let me
just ensure that all these softwares on
my system currently is in its latest
state
so sudo app get update
trade so that's done next thing we'll
actually install our docker
so type in sudo apt
get
install
docker
now as you can see here there's an error
that's occurred so sometimes it's
possible that due to the environment of
the machine that you're working in this
particular command does not work
in which case there's always another
command that you can start with
just type Docker install
and that by itself will give you the
commands you can use to install docker
so as it says here sudo apt install.io
is a command that we will need to
execute to install docker
and after that we'll execute the sudo
snap install Docker so sudo apt install
Docker dot IO first
and this will install your docker
after that's done we will have sudo snap
install Docker so snap install Docker
installs a newly created snap package
there are basically some other
dependencies for Docker that you'll have
to install
of course since this is the installation
process for the entire Docker i o it
will take some time
great so our Docker is installed the
next thing we do as I mentioned earlier
is that we need to install all the
dependency packages so the command for
that is
sudo snap install talk
enter your password
so with that we have completed the
installation process for Docker but
we'll perform a few more stages where we
will test if the installation has been
done right
so before we move on with the testing
for Docker let's once again just check
the version that we have installed
so for that the command is Docker
version
and as you can see Docker version
17.12.1 CE has been installed next thing
we do is we pull an image from the
docker hub so Docker run
hello
world
now hello world is a Docker image which
is present on the docker Hub Docker Hub
is basically a repository that you can
find online so with this command the
docker Mitch hello world has been pulled
onto your system
so let's see if it's actually present on
your system now the command to check
this
if pseudo Docker images
and as you can see here hello world
repository this is present on our system
currently so the image has been
successfully pulled onto the system and
this means that a Docker is working now
we'll try out another command
pseudo Docker PF minus a this displays
all the containers that you have pulled
so far so as you can see here there are
three hello world images displayed and
all of them are in exited state so I did
this demo previously too which is why
the two hello worlds which is created
two minutes ago is also displayed here
and the first hello world which has been
created a minute ago is the one we just
did for this demo now as you have
probably noticed that all the hello
world images over here all these
containers are in the exited state so
when you give the option for Docker PS
minus a where minus a stands for all it
displays all the containers whether they
are in exited or running state if you
want to see only those containers which
are in their running State you can
simply execute sudo Docker PS
pseudo docker
yes
and as you can see no container is
visible here because none of them are in
running state in this presentation we're
going to go through a number of key
things we're going to compare Docker
versus traditional virtual machines and
what are the differences and why you'd
want to choose Docker over a virtual
environment we'll go through the
advantages of working with Docker and
the structure and how you would build
out a Docker environment and during that
structure we'll dig through the
components and the advanced components
within Docker at the end of the
presentation we'll go through some basic
commands and then show you how those
basic commands can be used in a live
demo so with all that said let's get
started so let's first we'll compare
Docker with a traditional virtual
machine so here we have the architecture
on the left and right of a traditional
Virtual Machine versus a Docker
environment and there are some things
that you'll probably see immediately
that are big differences one is that the
virtual environment has hypervisor layer
whereas the environment has a Docker
engine layer and then in addition to
that there are additional layers within
the virtual machine each of these really
start compounding and creating very
significant differences between a Docker
environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts aggregating and
starts getting poorer whereas with
Docker the performance always stays
really good this is largely due to the
lightweight architecture used to
construct the docker containers
themselves if we look at portability
virtual machines just are terrible for
portability they're still dependent on
the host operating system and there's
just a lot of problems that happen when
you are using virtual machines for
portability in contrast Docker was
designed for portability so you can
actually build Solutions in a Docker
container environment and have the
guarantee that the solution will work as
you have built it no matter where it's
hosted finally boot up time the bit up
time for a virtual machine is fairly
slow in comparison to the boot up time
for a Docker environment which is almost
instantaneous so we look at these in a
little bit more detail one of the other
challenges that you have with a virtual
machine is that if you have unused
memory within the environment you cannot
reallocate that memory so if you set up
an environment that has nine gigs of
memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with Docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that Docker environment now
another challenge is running multiple
virtual machines in a single environment
I can lead to instability and
performance issues whereas Docker is
designed to run multiple containers in
the same environment and actually gets
better the more containers you run in
that hosted single Docker engine
portability issues with a virtual
machine is the software can work on one
machine but then when you move that VM
to another machine suddenly some of the
software won't work because there are
some dependencies that haven't been
inherited correctly whereas Docker
itself is designed specifically to be
able to run across multiple environments
and to be deployed very easily across
systems and again the actual boot up
time for a VM it just takes long time
you're talking about minutes in contrast
to the milliseconds that it takes for a
Docker environment to boot up so let's
dig into what Docker actually is and
what allows for these great performance
improvements over a traditional VM
environment so Docker itself is an OS
virtualized software platform and it
allows it organizations to really easily
create deploy and run applications as
what are called Docker containers that
have all the dependencies within that
container very easily and the container
itself is really just a very lightweight
package that has all the instructions
and dependencies such as Frameworks
libraries bins Etc all within that
container and that container itself can
then be moved from environment to
environment very easily if we to look in
our devops lifecycle the place where
Docker really shines is in deployments
because when you're actually at the
point of deploying Your solution you
want to be able to guarantee that the
code that has been tested will actually
work in the production environment but
in addition to that what we often find
is that when you're actually building
the code and you're actually testing the
code having a container running the
solution at those stages is also a
really good plus because what happens is
that the people building the code and
testing the code are able to validate
their work in the same environment that
would be used for the production
environment so really you can use Docker
in multiple stages within your devops
cycle but it becomes really valuable in
the deployment stage so let's look at
some of the key advantages that you have
with Docker some things that we've
already covered is that you can do rapid
deployments and you can do it really
fast the environment itself is highly
portable and was designed for that in
mind the efficiencies that you'll see
will allow you to run multiple Docker
containers in a single environment as
compared to more traditional VM
environments the configuration itself
can be scripted through a language
called yaml which allows you to be able
to write out and describe the docker
environment that you want to create this
in turn allows you to be be able to
scale your environment very very quickly
but with all of these advantages
probably the one that is most critical
to the type of work that we're doing
today is security you have to ensure
that the environment you are running is
a highly secure but highly scalable
environment and I'm very pleased to say
that Docker takes security very
seriously so you'll see it as one of the
key tenants for the actual architecture
of the system that you're implementing
so let's look at how doctor actually
works within your environment so Docker
works there is a what's called a Docker
engine the docker engine is really
comprised of the two is via rest API the
server as you can imagine has the
instructions that are communicated out
to the client and instructs the client
on what to do the connection between the
client and the server the communication
is via a rest API on older systems you
can take advantage of the docker toolbox
which allows you to go go ahead and
control the dean Docker compose and
kitomatic so let's now go into what the
actual root components though of Docker
are so let's have a look at those key
components there are four components
that we're going to go through we have
the docker clients and server we have
Docker images we have the docker
registry and the docker container we're
going to step through each of these one
by one so let's look at the docker
clients and server first so the docker
clients and server is a command line
instructed solution where you would use
terminal on your Mac or command line on
your PC or Linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker Daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via
arrest API so pull command which would
send an instruction to the Daemon which
would then form the interaction of
pulling in the correct components such
as an image or container or registry to
the docker client the docker Daemon
itself is actually a server which
actually performs all sorts of operating
and Performance Services and as you'd
imagine the docker Daemon is constantly
listing across the rest API to see if it
needs to perform any specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process what you want to do is use
the command payment and that will start
all of your performances and then you
have a Docker host which actually runs
the docker Damon and registry itself so
now let's look into the actual structure
of a Docker image so a Docker image
itself is a template which contains
instructions for the docker container
and that template is written with a
language called yaml and yaml stands for
yet another markup language it's very
easy to learn the docker image itself is
built within that yaml file and then
hosted as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers and you start with your
Baseline which will typically have your
base image in this instance is your base
operating system such as Ubuntu and then
you then have layer of dependencies
above that this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your Docker file so let's
just go through and look at what one of
those sets of instructions would look
like so here we have four layers of
instructions we have a from pull run and
then command so what does that actually
look like in our layers so to break this
down the from creates a layer which is
based on Ubuntu and then what we're
doing is we're adding in files from the
docker repository onto that base command
that base layer and then what we want to
be able to do is then say okay what are
the wrong commands so we can actually
then build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this in instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your Docker
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a Docker image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on right the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a Docker container the
docker's environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copy and write
strategy does make Docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for Docker it's just this
constant ability to be able to keep
improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself alright so let's go
on to item number three which is the
docker registry so the docker registry
itself is the place where you would host
and distribute the different types of
images that you have created or you want
to be used within your environment the
actual repository itself is just a
collection of Docker images and those
Docker images are built on instructions
that you would write with yaml and are
very easily stored and shared and what
you can actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual Docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see is we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifier and how we
actually use it to actually create the
actual container itself one of the
things you can do to start off how you
would manage or registry is you can
actually use the publicly accessible
Docker Hub registry which is available
to anybody but you can also create your
own registry for your own use internally
the actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and has been shared so again
full command um it pulls and retrieves a
Docker image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the registry
whether it's Docker Hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you knows in Docker registry
deleting a repository is not reversible
action so if you delete a repository
it's gone so let's go into the final
stage here which is the actual docker
container itself stations and its
dependencies bundled together so it
gives instructions that you would have
for the solution that you're looking to
run it's actually really like because of
the redundancy that's built into how you
structure the container and the
container itself is then inherently also
extremely portable what's really good
about running a container though is that
it does run completely in isolation so
you're able to share it very easily from
group to group and you are guaranteed
that even if you are running a container
it's not going to be impacted by any
host Os peculiarities or unique setups
as you would have in a VM or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a Docker
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vamp
you would have a defined amount of
memory for each VM environment the
change you start running into though is
that you can't share that memory whereas
with Docker you can easily share the
memory and for a single environment
across multiple containers the actual
container is built using Docker images
and the commands to actually run those
images is a run command so this can
actually go through a basic structure of
how you would run a Docker image so you
go into terminal window and you would
write a Docker run redis and then it
would run a container called redis so
we're going to go in and if you don't
have the redis image locally installed
it will then pull it from the registry
then the new Docker container redis will
be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so low lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within VMS and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced concepts within the docker
environment and we're going to look at
two Advanced components one is Docker
compose and the second is Docker swarm
so let's look at Docker compose Docker
compose is really designed for running
multiple containers as a single service
and it does this by running each
container in isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like Docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
Apache server with my SQL database and
you need to create a additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately this is where you would write
a set of files using Docker compose to
be able to help balance out that demand
so let's now look at Docker swarm so
Docker swarm is a service that allows
you to be able to control multiple
Docker environments within a single
platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your Docker
swamp is we're treating each node as a
Docker Daemon and we're actually having
an API that's interacting with each of
those nodes there are two types of nodes
that you're going to be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the manager node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to and receive updates from the
working node so if anything happens
within this environment the major node
can react and adjust the architecture of
the worker node so it's always in sync
it was really great for a large scaled
environments so finally let's go through
what are some of the basic commands
you'd use within Docker and once we've
gone through all these basic commands
we'll actually show you a demo of how
you'd actually use them as well so if
we're going to go in probably the first
command is to install Docker and so if
you have yam installed you just do yum
install Docker and you'll install Docker
onto your computer to start the docker
Daemon is you want to do system CTL
start Docker the command to remove a
Docker image as Docker RMI and then the
image ID itself and that's not the image
name that's the actual alphanumeric ID
number that you want to grab the command
line to download a new image is Docker
pull and then the name of the image
you'd want to pull and by default you're
going to be pulling from the docker
default registry that will then connect
to your Docker demon and download the
images from that registry the command
line to run an image is Docker run and
then the image ID and then we have the
if we wanted to pull specifically from
Docker Hub then we would have a Docker
pull and then the image name and colon
It's tag to pull build an image from a
Docker file you would do Docker build
Dash T and then the image name and colon
tag to shut down the container you do
Docker stop container ID the access for
running a container is Docker exec it
container ID bash so we've gone through
all the different commands but let's
actually see how they would actually
look and we're going to go ahead and do
a demo so welcome to this demo where
we're going to go ahead and put together
all of the different commands that we
have outlined in the presentation for
Docker first is just to list all of the
docker images that we have so we do sudo
Docker images and we enter in our
password
and this will Now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a Docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull and then the name
of the image that we want to pull which
is going to be my SQL
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest MySQL
command MySQL image that we have so it's
now going to head and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you can see the others have completed
just wait for this last file to download
almost there once that's done we're
going to go ahead and do is we'll
actually run the docking container and
create a new container using the image
that we just downloaded but we have to
wait for this to download First
all right so the image has been pulled
from Docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
Docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run Dash D
Ash p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon 80
colon 80.
and then put in my SQL
call on latest so we have the latest
version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new Docker container
has been created
and let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo Docker a lot of
updation in the operating what needs to
be updated at first and as the
requirements of the company change the
infrastructures configuration needs to
change and finally of course the people
need coordination so if you have a team
of system administrators and say person
a makes some change to the code person B
C D and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as to why it was made
what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so
Direction here are the notes pushes
these files onto the node so the
complete control lies with the server on
your right side we have the pull
configuration in case of pull
configuration the notes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files Chef follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in a video another important
term often used with Chef infrastructure
as code so let's understand what this
term infrastructure as code means
through this small story so here's Tim
Tim's system administrator at a large
company now he receives a task he has to
set up a server and he has to install 20
software applications over it so he
begins he sets up the server but then it
hits him it would take him the entire
night to install 20 software
applications wouldn't things have been
much simpler if he just had a code to do
so well of course codes do make things
much simpler codes have a number of
advantages they're easily modifiable so
if today Tim is told we need MySQL
installed on 20 systems Tim simply
writes a code to do so and the very next
day term is told we changed our mind we
don't need Maya skill I think we'll just
use Oracle this does not bothered him
because now he just opens the a file he
makes a few Corrections in his code and
that should work just fine code is also
testable so if Tim had to write 10
commands to do something and at his 10th
command he realized the very first
command he wrote there was something not
right there well that would be quite
tiresome wouldn't it with codes however
you can test it even before running it
and all the bugs can be caught and
corrected codes are also Deployable so
they're easily Deployable and they're
Deployable multiple times so now that we
saw the various advantages of having
codes let's say what infrastructure as
code exactly is here's the definition
infrastructure as code is a type of it
infrastructure where the operation team
manages the code rather than a manual
procedure so infrastructure as a code
allows the operations team to take care
of a code which automatically performs
various procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
Chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of Chef are written in
Ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
nodes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be posted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes oh hi is
a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required Chef client is
another such service on your node which
is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
Chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
sauce you have simply learned three dot
Erb Erb is the extension for your Ruby
files so the cookbooks are only created
at the workstation they now need to be
sent over to the server where they are
stored and this is the task of the knife
knife is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
Dash DB where simply Dash DB is the name
of the cookbook we then move on to our
node machines at our nodes We Run The oi
service the oi service will collect all
information regarding the current state
of your notes and send it over to the
chef client when you run the chef client
these informations are sent over to the
server and they are tested against the
cookbooks so if there is any discrepancy
between the current state of your nodes
and the cookbook that is if one of the
notes does not match the configurations
required The cookbook is in the server
and executed at the node this sets the
node to the right State there are
various flavors of Chef built through
these first we have Chef solo with Chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the Node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of the next flavor is a hosted
chef with hosted Chef you still have
your workstation and your node but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical Chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
shift client server with shift client
server you have a workstation you have
server and you have n number of nodes
now this is the traditional Chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private Chef private
Chef is also known as Enterprise Chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
Enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between shaft line
server and private Chef in case of Chef
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the Enterprise
version of Chef also provides the
Liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the Hands-On so before we dive into our
demo let me me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both Centos 7 one will be
used as workstation while the other will
be a node so we are just using one node
to make things simple the server will be
used as a service on the cloud now these
are the steps we'll be performing during
our demo we'll first download and
install the chef DK on our workstation
we then make an empty cookbook file and
we'll write a recipe into it we need to
then set up the server so as I mentioned
earlier server will be a service on the
cloud so you'll have to create a profile
but this will be completely free we then
link the workstation to the server and
we'll upload the recipe to the server
the nodes will now download the
cookbooks from the server and configure
themselves so now that you have some
idea about what we'll be doing let's
move on to the actual demo We Begin our
demo here's my Oracle VM virtualbox
manager I have two machines here I have
already created my workstation and node
both of these are sent to a 7 machine
just for you to differentiate this is my
terminal and for my workstation it's a
black background with white text and as
of my node it's a black background with
green text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for Chef DK installation
go to the first link which is your
Chef's official page a very warm welcome
to all our viewers I'm Anjali from
Simply learn and today I'll be showing
you how you can install the
configuration management tool ansible so
let's have a brief about why one would
use ansible and what exactly is ansible
so if you consider the case of an
organization it has a very large
infrastructure which means it has more
than probably hundreds of systems and
giving one or even a small team of
people the responsibility to configure
all these systems makes their work
really tough repetitive and as you know
manual work is always prone to errors so
ansible is a tool which can automate the
configuration of all these systems with
ansible a small team of system
administrators can write simple code in
yaml and these codes are deployed onto
the hundreds and thousands of servers
which configures them to the desired
States so ansible automates
configuration management that is
figuring your systems it automates
orchestration which means it brings
together a number of applications and
decides an order in which these are
executed and it also automates
deployment of the applications now that
we know what ansible does let's move on
to the installation of ansible so here
is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager I'll
be using two systems there's the node
system which is basically my client
system and there's a server system or
the Master System so let's begin at our
server system
so this is my Master System guys so the
first thing we do is we download our
ansible tool
so one or puppet ansible is a push type
of configuration management tool so what
this means is that the entire control
here lies with your master or your
server system this is where you write
your configuration files and these are
also responsible for pushing these
configuration files onto your node or
client system as and when required
printer ansible tool is installed now we
need to open a ansible host file and
there we'll specify the details of our
node or client machine
host file as you can see here the entire
file is commented but there's a certain
syntax that you'd observe for example
here we have a group name web servers
under which we have the IP addresses a
certain host name so this is about how
we'll be adding the details for our
client system first we need to give a
group name
under this group basically we add all
the clients which require a certain type
of configuration since we are using just
one node we'll give only the details for
that particular node first we need to
add the IP address of our client machine
so let's just go back to our client
machine
and this here is the IP address
192.168.2.11
once you have typed in your IP address
give a space and then we'll specify the
user for a client machine
so all Communications between the server
or the Master System and the client or
the node system takes place through SSH
ssh basically provides a secure channel
for the transfer of information
follow this up with your password in my
case it's the roots password
and that's it we are done so now we save
this to our terminal
so now that our host file is written the
next thing we do is we write a Playbook
so Playbook is the technical term used
for all the configuration files that we
write in ansible now playbooks are
written in yaml yaml's extremely simple
to both write and understand it's in
fact very close to English
first starts with three dashes this
indicates the beginning of your file
next thing we need to give a name to our
Playbook
so name
and I'm going to name my playbook sample
book
we next need to specify our host systems
which is basically the systems at which
the configuration file or the playbook
in our case will be executed so we'll be
executing this at the client machines
mentioned under the group ansible
servers so we had just one client
machine under it we'll still mention the
group name
we next need to specify the username
with which we'll be logging into our
client machine
which is Root in my case
and become true specifies that you need
to become the root to execute this
Playbook so becoming the roots called a
privilege escalation next we need to
specify our tasks so these are basically
the actions that the Playbook will be
performing so you would have noticed
everything so far is aligned that is
name host remote user become and task
because these are at one level now
whatever comes under task will be
shifted slightly towards the right
although yamil is extremely simple to
understand and read both it's a little
tricky while writing because you need to
be very careful about the indentations
and the spacing
so my first task is install httpd which
is basically a Apache server
so now my command yum and this will be
installing the httpd package
and the latest state of it will be
installed so that's our first task now
our second task could be running our
Apache service
so name run httpd
and the action which is service
will be performed on httpd hence the
name httpd
and state must be started
now we come to our third task
so here we'll create a very simple web
page that will be hosted
so create content is the name of our
task
and the content that we are creating
here will basically be copied to a node
system at a particular file location
that will provide
a Content will be congrats
and then we'll provide the destination
at which this file will be copied
so this is the default location for Ola
HTML files
and that's it we are done writing our
Playbook
just save this and go back to your
terminal
before we execute the Playbook or push
the Playbook onto our node system let's
check the syntax of our Playbook so the
command for doing so is
and if everything is fine with your
playbook the output would be just your
playbook name so our syntax is perfectly
fine now we can push on the Playbook to
our node or the client machine
and that's the Syntax for doing so now
as your playbook is being sent over to
the client machine you can see that
first the facts are gathered that is the
current state of your client machine is
first fetched to check what all is to be
changed and what is already present so
the first thing is installing httpd so
our system already had httpd so it says
okay because this does not need to be
changed and next task was running httpd
now Although our system had the Apache
service it was not running so that is
one thing that was changed the next was
there was no content available so the
content was also added so two tasks were
changed and four things were okay now
everything seems fine and before you
move any forward it is very important
that you check this one line of
documentation provided by ansible you
have all kind of information available
here regarding which all tasks were
executed if your client machine was
reachable or unreachable and so on so
now that everything is fine here we can
move on to our node system
and we'll just go to our browser so if
our Playbook has been executed here what
should happen is that the httpd service
must be in the running State and the
webpage that we created should be hosted
so let's just type localhost
and great everything's working fine so
our web page is displayed here so we
come to an end for our installation and
configuration video for the
configuration management tool ansible if
you have any doubts please post them in
the comment section below and we'll
definitely get back to you as soon as
possible ansible today as one of the key
tools that you would have within your
devops environment so the things that
we're going to go through today is we're
going to cover why you would want to use
a product like ants for what ansible
really is and how it's of value to you
in your organization the differences
between ansible and other products that
are similar to it on the market and what
makes ansible a compelling product and
I'm going to dig into the architecture
for ansible we're going to look at how
you would create a Playbook how you
would manage your inventory of your
server environments and then what is the
actual workings of ansible there's a
little extra we're going to also throw
in ansible Tau one of the secret Source
solutions that you can use for improving
the Speed and Performance of how you
create your ansible environments and
finally we're going to go through a use
Case by looking at HootSuite social
media management company and how they
use ansible to really improve the
efficiency within their organizations so
let's jump into this so the big question
is why ansible so you have to think of
ansible as another tool that you have
within your devops environment for
helping manage the servers and this
definitely falls on the operations side
of the devops equation so if we look
here we have a picture of Sam and like
yourselves Sam is a system administrator
and he is responsible for maintaining
the infrastructure for all the different
servers within his company so some of
the servers that he may have that he has
to maintain could be web servers running
Apache they could be database servers
running my Sequel and if you only have a
few servers then that's fairly easy to
maintain I mean if you have three web
servers and two database servers and
let's face it will we all love just to
have one or two servers to manage it
would be really easy to maintain the
trick however is as we start increasing
the number of servers and this is a
reality of the environments that we live
and operate in it becomes increasingly
difficult to create consistent setup of
different infrastructures such as web
servers and databases for the simple
reason that we're all human as if we had
to update and maintain all of those
servers by hand there's a good chance
that we would not set up each server
identically now this is where ansible
really comes to the rescue and helps you
become an efficient operations team
ansible like other system Solutions such
as chef and puppet uses code that you
can write and describe the installation
and setup of your servers so you can
actually repeat it and deploy those
servers consistently into multiple areas
so now you don't have to have one person
redoing and re-following setup
procedures you just write one script and
then each script can be executed and
have a consistent environment so we've
gone through why you'd want to use
ansible let's step through what ansible
really is so yeah this is all great but
you know how do we actually use these
tools in our environment so ansible is a
tool that really is node and then within
quotes insert the hostname of your node
system
so my note system toast name is client
the package you wish to install which in
our case is httpd
and the action to be performed
and that's it a very small and simple
code save this file
now let's go back to our node system and
let's pull this second version of the
same configuration file so every time
you execute this command as we did
previously to what happens is the agent
service so the agent service basically
checks on your master system if there's
any new configuration file added or if
there's any change to the previous
configuration file made if so then the
catalog is applied once again so now our
catalogs applied in 1.55 seconds so now
to check if our catalog served its
purpose let's just open our browser
just type localhost here
and as you can see if your httpd package
has been successfully installed the
Apache testing page will appear here so
in this session what we can do is we're
going to cover what and why you would
use puppets what are the different
elements and components of puppet and
how does it actually work and then we'll
look into the companies that are
adopting puppet and what are the
advantages that they have now received
by having puppet within their
organization and finally we'll wrap
things up by reviewing how you can
actually write a manifest in puppet so
let's get started so why puppet so here
is a scenario that as an administrator
you may already be familiar with you as
an administrator have multiple servers
that you have to work with and manage so
what happens when a server goes down
it's not a problem you can jump onto
that server and you can fix it but what
if the scenario changes and you have
multiple servers going down so here is
where publish shows its strap with
puppets all you have to do is write a
simple script that can be written with
Ruby and write out and deploy to the
servers your settings for each of those
servers the code gets pushed out now to
the servers that are having problems and
then you can choose to either roll back
to those servers to their previous
working States or set them to a new
state and do all of this in a matter of
seconds and it doesn't matter how large
your server environment is you can reach
to all of these servers your environment
is secure you're able to deploy your
software and you're able to do this all
through infrastructure as code which is
the advanced devops model for building
out Solutions so let's dig deeper into
what puppet actually is so puppet is a
configuration management tool maybe
similar tools like Chef that you may
already be familiar with it ensures that
all your systems are configured to a
desired and predictable state public can
also be used as a deployment tool for
software what automatically you can
deploy your software to all of your
systems or to specific systems and this
is all done with code this means you can
test the environment and you can have a
guarantee that the environment you want
is written and deployed accurately so
let's go through those components of
Puppets so here we have a breakdown of
the puppet environment and on the top we
have the main server environment and
then below that we have the client
environment that would be installed on
each of the servers that would be
running within your network so if we
look at the top part of the screen we
have here our puppet master store which
has and contains our main configuration
files and those are comprised of
manifests that are actual codes for
configuring the clients we have
templates that combine our codes
together to render a final document and
you have files that will be deployed as
content that could be potentially
downloaded by the clients wrapping this
all together is a module of mass office
templates and files you would apply a
certificate authority to sign the actual
documents so that the clients actually
know that they're receiving the
appropriate and authorized modules
outside of the master server where you'd
create your manifest templates and files
you would have public clients as a piece
of software that is used to configure a
specific machine there are two parts to
the client one is the agent that
constantly interacts with the master
server to ensure that the certificates
are being updated appropriately and then
you have the fact that the current state
of the client that is used and
communicated back to through the agent
so let's step through the workings of
puppet so the puppet environment is a
Master Slave architecture the clients
themselves are distributed across your
network and they are constantly
communicating back to a Master server
environment where you have your puppet
modules the client agent sends a
certificate with the ID of that server
back to the master and then the master
will then sign their certificate and
send it back to the client and this
authentication allows for a secure and
verifiable communication between clients
and master the factor then collects the
state of the client and sends that to
the master based on the facts sent back
the master then compiles manifests into
the catalogs and those catalogs are sent
back to the clients and an agent on the
client will then initiate the catalog a
report is generated by the client that
describes any changes that have been
made and sends that back to the master
with the goal here of ensuring that the
master has full understanding of the
hardware running software in your
network this process is repeated at
regular infos ensuring all client
systems are up to date so let's have a
look at companies that are using puppets
today there are a number of companies
that have adopted puppet as a way to
manage their infrastructure so companies
that are using public today include
Spotify Google ATT so why are these
companies choosing to use puppet as
their main configuration management tool
the answer can be seen if we look at a
specific company Staples so Staples
chose to take and use puppet for their
configuration management tool and use it
within their own private Cloud the
results were dramatic the amount of time
that the it organization was able to
save in deploying and managing their
infrastructure through using puppets
enabled them to open up time to allow
them to expound with other and new
projects and assignments a real tangible
benefit to a company so let's look at
how you write a manifest in puppets so
so manifests are designed for writing
out in code how you would configure a
specific node in your server environment
the manifests are compiled into catalogs
which are then executed on the client
each of the Manifest are written in the
language of Ruby without dot PP
extension if we step through the five
key steps for writing a manifest they
are one create your manifest and that is
written by the system administrator two
compile your Manifest this compiles into
a catalog three deploy the catalog is
then deployed onto the clients for
execute the catalogs are run on the
client by the agent and clients are
configured to a specific and desired
state if we actually look into how
manifest is written it's written with a
very common syntax if you've done any
work with Ruby or really configuration
of systems in the past this may look
very familiar to you so we break out the
work that we have here you start off
with a package file or service as your
resource type and then you give it a
name and then you look at the features
that need to be set such as IP address
then you're actually looking to have a
command written such as present or start
the Manifest can can contain multiple
resource types if we continue to write
our manifesting puppets the default
keyword applies a manifest to all
clients so an example would be to create
a file path that creates a folder called
sample in a main folder called Etc the
specified content is written into a file
that is then posted into that folder and
then we're going to say we want to be
able to trigger an Apache service and
then ensure environment that you're
looking to manage that will determine
which of these four tools you should use
the tools themselves are open source so
go out and experiment with them there's
a lot of videos our team has done a ton
of videos on these tools and so feel
free to find out other tools that we
have then covered so you can learn very
quickly how to use them but consider the
requirements that you have and consider
the capabilities of your team if you
have Ruby developers or you have someone
on your team that knows Ruby your bill
ability to choose a broader set of tools
becomes much more interesting if however
you're new to coding then you may want
to consider yaml based tools again the
final answer is going to be up to you
and we'll be really interested on what
your decision is
monitoring as the term says you're
monitoring you're watching your
logging your production environment so
of course there are a whole bunch of
management tools so they become that
important part of your production
environment and a lot of these
monitoring tools are also I've seen the
worshiping used especially in your UAP
environment and you can optionally have
them for some time even in your you know
development environment no not not
development business development servers
are usually not very uh
high-end configurations but you know
maybe a decent development slash
integration
server especially if you have a long
running scripts and if you have programs
that use a lot of servers uh you know
maybe CPU or processing power so then
you can have monitoring tools when
you're writing such scripts and you know
you are doing the UA unit testing for
those scripts so that you know to see uh
what kind of server utilization
happens when you run this script you
know if you'll put this in production
will it actually you know slow down your
uh production server and what kind of uh
impact that will have on the you know
your rest of your application or other
applications running on that server
but the this particular chapter is more
in context with production environment
so these uh tools they basically monitor
your server they monitor your switches
of course they want to your applications
and any services that you have deployed
on your servers and they generate alerts
when something goes wrong and that's the
whole job of monitoring it is
continuously watching continuously
looking at what is running what is
happening what is going up what is going
down when it's CPU peaking when it's
memory peaking and all that so that you
can you typically send limits for these
uh all these different parameters and
anytime any of these parameters goes
outside of that limit you know even more
than that or less than that these
monitoring tools usually send out an
alert uh and these alerts could again be
SMS alert the email alerts and there are
there are usually people monitoring
these monitoring tools uh to look look
out for any
issues reported and they also generate
alerts that the problem has been
resolved so it was worth it
scenarios is an open source monitoring
tool and it can
even monitor your network services
it's a little diagram here which is
too small
but here is somewhere what I can read
these are different devices
I think no no no yeah these are
different devices to which nagios is
sending the status there's a browser
there's an SMS there's an email and then
there's a graph also and these are
different objects that nagios is
basically monitoring this is an SMTP so
I can read SMTP
this is
I don't know PCP no I don't know some
database level okay this is a database
server and this is an application server
then you switch router okay okay I can
read that now so this is the different
kind of object these are different kind
of servers that Nature's monitors and
these are the different kind of
uh devices or statuses that it can send
so it helps monitor your CPU usage your
dispute page and you know even your
system logs and it uses the plugin
script that can be written you know in
any scripting language actually yeah
do not use remote plugin executors are
basically agents that allow remote
scripts to be executed as well and these
scripts are usually executed to
monitors again your CPU just you say
number of users logged in who is logged
in who's logged in what time logged out
at what time and all these happening so
all these monitoring tools work on the
concept of polling
so
polling is more like you know they
should NRP agent is a program that will
continuously keep polling a machine for
certain parameters that are configured
energies to be monitored so this program
continues to keep pinging the server
bringing the program
uh you know to keep checking for what it
has been asked to check so in case of
logged in users you keep checking uh at
a you know like maybe every 30 seconds
or every one minute you keep uh pinging
uh to see how many users have logged in
onto this server and who are the users
who have logged in what time they logged
in what time they logged out and things
like that
that can you know help you uh
poll or things even remote machine
the nadios remote data processor is an
agent that allows the you know flexible
data transport and you know it uses the
HTTP and XML protocols to do that
and we're talking about the essentially
your databases and
data Servo usage is like you know so
then if you have an Oracle database how
many database instances are there you
know how
your load balancing is set up on that
how data is moving between different uh
database servers within Oracle and how
data is moving within the load balancers
and there's always a DRP there's always
a backup with database so that's why you
preemie mentioned trp as soon as I say
the word database and it is a backup
plan you know
uh how how's the data moving how much
time did the backup take did it take too
much time and why you know why did it
take it helps you do all those kind of
monitoring
the NS client is basically mainly used
to monitor Windows machines and
typically when we talk about servers
we end up talking more about you know
Unix non-linux servers of course now
with a lot of Microsoft
Technologies being robust damping itself
and there are some small checks that
needs to be done so and by default
Jenkins Launches on the port 8080 so let
me just open up localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I will have to just copy
this path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical RPM kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see
there is a whole lot of plugins which
are bare essential plugin that is
required for Jenkins in order to run
properly so Jenkins as a part of the
installation would get all these plugins
and then install it for you this is a
good combination to kind of begin with
and mind you at this moment Jenkins
needs lots of bandwidth in terms of
network so in case your you know your
network is not so good few of these
plugins would kind of fail and these
plugins are all you know all available
on openly or or mirrored sites and
sometimes some of them may be down so do
not worry in case some of these plugins
kind of fail to install you'll get an
option to kind of retry installing them
but just ensure that you know at least
most or 1995 of all these plugins are
installed without any problems let me
pause the video here for a minute and
then get back once all these plugins are
installed my plugin installation is all
good there was no failures in any of my
plugins so after that I get to create
this first admin user again this is one
important point that you got to remember
given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and um an email ID is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case I don't so I just
given an admin and I get a password I've
got I remember my password this is my
full name all right I say seven finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configuration
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI people to wrap their head around it
specifically the windows guys but if at
all your Java guy you know how painful
it is to write UI in Java you would kind
of appreciate you know all the effort
that has gone into the UI bottom line
you always little hard to you know wrap
your head around it but once you start
using it possibly you'll start liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkins
know at any point in time how many jobs
or how many threads can be run you can
kind of visualize it like a thread that
can be run on this particular instance
as a thumb rule if at all you're on a
single core system number of executors
two should be good enough in case at any
point in time if there are multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that are
there to open up no need to panic
because they will all get queued up and
eventually Jenkins will get to running
those jobs just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the CPU usage and the memory
usage in terms of the disk right is very
high on the Jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out there by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would want Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email ID
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using SMTP Port
which is 465 and I'm you know reply to
address is the same as mine I can just
send out an email and see if at all this
configuration works again Gmail would
not allow you to allow anybody to send
out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test in email
with the configuration that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to managing
cans okay one other thing that I want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool set that is
required or what is the code that is
going to be understand until you want to
restart Jenkins once in a while but as a
good practice whenever you do some sort
of a big installations or big patches on
your Jenkins instance just ensure that
you kind of restart it otherwise there
would be a difference in terms of what
is installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which they would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now all right so this comes
in because of my installation of my role
based plugin so this is what I would
want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
where is this configure configure Global
Security is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the roles are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project roles and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer and I'm adding
this role at a global role level so I
would say add this here and you would
see this developer role that is there
and each of these options you can click
hover over it you would see some sort of
a help on what what are these uh you
know permissions specific to so what I
want is like you know it sounds a little
you know different but I would want to
give very very little permissions for
the developer so from an Administration
perspective I would just want him to
have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read-only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
I would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured out of the
system and developer one is a user that
I have configured so still have not set
any rules for this particular user yet
so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign rules I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that had created so developer I would
assign this developer 1 to this
particular Global rule and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges so there you
go I have gen games but I don't see a
new item I can't trigger a new job I
can't do anything I see these jobs
however I don't think so I'll be able to
start this job I don't have the
permission set for that the maximum I
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console